good morning this is um environment
agriculture committee and I would like
and I would request representative
Murray please lead us in the Pledge of
Allegiance this
morning to the flag of the United States
of America and to the Republic for which
it stands one nation under God
all good morning
everyone
we're in we took a fi trip today we're
room on today's docket at 10 o'clock we
are working uh doing a um committee work
session to just sort of have a little
discussion about um four bills that
we've
heard representative dsy please right
there there you
go
uh so we have four bills that we're
going to uh just briefly
discuss
um the first one is HB 1386 relative to
prohibiting the disposal of lithium ion
batteries in solid waste fac landfill
facilities composting facilities or
incinerators and um I just wanted to get
a quick read from the committee members
who are here I know we have a a few who
will be absent today and um to who will
be late but I I just wanted to get a
quick read from our committee um
regarding that bill I know
representative eel introduced the bill
and also um had presented uh an
amendment to that bill having to do with
um noticing that um if if something gets
thrown into the squash or into the
incinerator or some other place in a
landfill by accident that there would be
uh you know they would be held harmless
for um an inadvertent
action and um I just wanted to get an um
feedback from the committee on um on
this bill what you think if it needs any
other further amendments representative
Bixby yeah so um I think that the the
bill with the suggested amendment makes
sense and we had had some discussion
about uh adding lithium batteries as
well as lithium ion batteries to that
and uh we got an email from uh
representative eel last night uh
indicating that uh they're are
forwarding something from the uh
Northeast um the nrra I however that
comes out in uh so um suggesting that
that might actually complicate things uh
because of the um in in terms of
educating people about how to separate
the different items um I I think that it
makes sense you to um probably not go
into not adding the lithium because um
um I I think that you know people still
do sometimes separate out the lithium
batteries but I think that which is good
but it's um but I think that for the
purposes of this bill the bigger danger
is the lithium ion batteries because
they're more reactive I would agree
thank you any other comment
representative
Duty yeah correct me if I'm wrong but
when I went over the bill I noticed
there's an education piece but I didn't
notice a piece for collection so you
know I mean so I may be educated about
not putting lithium ion batteries into
the waist stream but but you know is
there anything in this spill and I
didn't see it uh for collection
sites I see the sponsor shaking her head
um I I did catch the uh testimony from
nhma n Hamshire Municipal Association
who said that um many of the collection
sites transfer stations already separate
these things out and so they're okay
with it with the bill as it
is represent Murray correct me if I'm
wrong uh as far as the educational piece
too I know that education can also be
defined as signage or those types of
things that that's an educational
component to the public and I think
there was some discussion around uh
third party entities that would be open
to helping out with that M um through
other organizations to help transfer
stations educate the public on what's
disposable and what should be kept out
right and I also am aware that U Dees
has on their website also information
about how to recycle certain things so
yeah I think I think that that's going
to start filtering down and filtering
out to to the public so representative
gron uh yes ma'am I I support the bill
as amended
um the one thing that I was concerned
about was the addition of the lithium
batteries but the word we got back to
add to representative bixby's comment
was that they those are not a fire risk
um nearly as much as the other ones are
and so I'm I'm perfectly fine not adding
that in and going with the bill as
amended over okay represent
kto thank you madam chair and I think uh
being aware of lithon and ion and the
fire has it is extremely important um
and I understand why they should not be
in
landfills but my question is is what is
the industry that is putting these
lithium ion batteries into the products
um are they looking for Alternatives and
other ways to uh because if these if
people do not recycle these and we
continue because we pass this and say
that they cannot be put in there doesn't
mean that the occasional one or few are
not going to be put in there and we're
going to still end up having um these
fires which are horrid um so is the
industry looking for alternative energy
sources to get away from the lithium
batteries ion batteries is my
question I don't really know the answer
to that um but I would hope that they
would also put something on their
packaging to indicate that um there the
the batteries that are contained in
there could are flammable yeah
representative Bixby yeah I think that
uh the industry is
um well there there are two things one
is that there are uh there's Research
into alternatives to lithiumion
batteries I don't think
that the there's going to be a rapid
change in the use of them because uh
they are at this point a an established
technology that is known to work uh the
they if you look at when you get a
computer when you get a um a tablet when
you get a uh a tool with a re
rechargeable battery on it if you look
at it you see that it you says you know
recycle this properly don't you know
don't landfill it uh so there and um
places like Home Depot and flows have
bins outside saying put lithium ion
batteries here uh so there
are there are uh efforts from the
industry to um make people aware of it I
think that if those efforts are then uh
uh Amplified by what we have by
education at the municipal level and at
the um the land you know the transfer
help okay um representative
Howard thank you madam chair I could you
could you remind me of the amendment
1396 so this
amendment
um is amendment 2024 d49
basically um prohibits the disposal of
wet cell and lithium ion batteries and
electronic devices in any Solid Waste
landfill facility or incinerator in New
Hampshire the amendment requires towns
Solid Waste districts and owners
operators of landfills and incinerators
to make educational materials available
on the prohibition but it
also
um says that
um that
the these if any of these lithium ion
batteries do get put into the squash or
end up in the landfill that it's the the
people doing that are not held liable
for that because they make people make
know all right I think um I think we're
okay then with with this amendment and
probably not going to be adding in
lithium batteries that might be
something for future legislation if we
consider that I'm going to move on to HB
1376 relative to prohibiting certain
packaging from carrying the recycling
logo anybody care to lend a comment
Bill not representative Bixby so um I I
recognize that there's a feeling of
deception when uh you hear news reports
that things with the recycling logo
aren't getting recycled but I think that
the utility of those recycling logos far
outweighs the uh the perception of De of
deception so uh at our trans at transfer
stations all across the state people are
encouraged to put their number ones in
one container their number twos in
another container uh and so forth and
you might not be able to put your number
seven some in a container but the fact
that you can put the number one in your
contain in that container means that
your municipality can uh get money for
those number ones uh and instead of
having to pay a tipping fee on it if
your municipality can get a A reduced
cost disposal for the number twos
instead of paying a larger tipping fee
and in some cases the same thing with
number five
so the ability to sort that is an
important Financial uh factor for
municipal transfer stations uh it's not
as it's not a big it doesn't come into
play when you have a a single sort
operation uh like some of our our larger
municipalities have but it's really
critical for our smaller municipalities
that have transport stations to have
those logo logos to help people figure
out where to put the the different types
of plastic so I think this is I don't
think this bill makes sense
representative K thank you madam chair
um I will concur with uh representative
Bixby that I don't believe that this
bill makes sense I think if you were
going to do something like this it would
basically have to be done on the federal
level and I actually think that having a
logo even though some of them may not be
as accurate as they should be we are
educating the consumer to look for them
um and therefore guiding them towards
the numbers also associated with those
packaging um and to me that's
educational um when it comes to
recycling anyone else representative
Duty um yes thank you madam chair um yes
I I agree with uh the previous comments
uh when I read this bill I I would
actually like to see um a different form
of this bill and and that is one kind of
like that oversight by exception so that
when when it appears that a company is
deceptively labeling their product like
I mentioned about my bird seed
containers okay that you know perhaps we
have an an oversight agency the dees who
contacts the company or we have a law
that makes it clear if you choose to put
a recycling logo on your product okay
that you are then responsible for
ensuring that that product can be
recycled somewhere in that state okay
and I don't think that I don't think
there would be a lot of complaints uh
but I think companies should be held
accountable when there's the appearance
of recycling and yet you contact them
and there's nowhere to recycle it so so
I would agree that I I do think this
bill is something that should be done at
the federal level um but but that we
might want to look at something like
that by exception next year okay thank
you thank you okay represent ger thank
you madam chair uh I agree with a lot of
what's been said and and as with a lot
of the labeling bills that we get uh
even when they are good ideas at at root
there's the larger problem of you know
one small state can't really dictate
kind of how companies label their their
products uh will only say that I think
that one of the arguments that
representative Kaplan made which I think
was a compelling one is that this would
give the Attorney General's office an
instrument right it it doesn't mean that
there has to be
um you know rigorous enforcement but it
does give the Attorney General's uh
office a tool that they could use in
cases like representative Duty referred
to to then write a letter to companies
and say look this law exists and it is
unlawful in the state of New Hampshire
to provide this type of misinformation
so I I understand and I agree with the
direction that that we seem to be headed
in but I do want to point out that I
think that was a good argument the
representative Kaplan made about how a
law like this could be used thank you
thank
you all right why don't we um move on to
HB
1681 relative to the products labeled as
biodegradable or
compostable and um I believe um
representative parshall who introduced
the bill he also brought with him some
ideas for an amendment which would have
placed um the language in Commerce law
and what I've been
um
in educated about by our house clerk is
that um we can't adopt an amendment that
would Place uh this bill in a section of
law that we have no purview over so it
seems to me that um and when I've had
discussions with representative parall
as well uh that he he has been advised
to speak to the chair uh and ranking
member and folks over at the Commerce uh
committee to see if there's a bill that
his language can be placed in as an
amendment um baring that it's his
language could be brought up to a a new
bill next year um and with that I
believe that we would have to itl the
bill as it is now and have him uh pursue
that that Avenue representative Bixby
yeah I'd like
to I'd like to thank our chair for
having contacted the clerk to
determine what uh the rules are
regarding uh
amending amending bills that would end
up in a different committee's perview
and I think that uh I I like the concept
of this bill I think that there need
there need to be a few tweaks to it but
uh if if this committee can't uh by
house rules put the right Amendment on
the bill I think what we have to do is
uh move an itl on it and hope that
there's some Bill that it could be added
to in Commerce
and if that doesn't work then try again
next year or even maybe the Senate he
could approach a senator and put it on a
Senate Bill
too
okay all right and that leaves um HB oh
I'm sorry representative ger I missed
you that's thank you very much wave your
arms uh I just as as a co-sponsor on
this bill as well I wanted to to agree
that I I think that the section of the
law that represents Senator parshall is
suggesting in his amendment makes sense
and I also appreciate the the work
you've done Madam chair and and seeing
what the possibilities are and that
definitely those options make sense you
know a bill that's in Commerce or a
Senate Bill uh but it's probably not
something we can do anything about thank
you thank you all
right okay so that leaves HB 154
relative to architectural paint
we have a um any comment about that
representative Duty thank you madam
chair um some other information has has
come to light and I want to thank our
researcher uh Kristen Grant uh for all
the information she provided so if
you'll indulge me just a little bit um I
W I had I had received um model
legislation from the American codings
Association and the American codings
Association uh works with all paint
manufacturers and has all paint
manufacturers signed up for the um
recycling of paint and they work through
an organization that was mentioned last
week paint care okay um so I read the
bill that was presented to the committee
in 2020 when I was a freshman I think a
few others of us were freshman uh Bill
HB 1570 and I said wow this bill sounds
like the model legislation bill that I
just read and in fact it was so
representative Parell and I had a a zoom
meeting uh with uh American coding
Association representative Heidi mcalli
okay and what she did over the weekend
was take HB
1570 and their current model
legislation okay and and amended 1570
with the model
legislation um so I would hope and this
is going to be Revenue neutral so the
way it works is that there will be
locations in the in the state um that
will accept recycled paint uh they work
Ace Hardware is one of them that they
work with and they work with some others
okay and then the collection um or the
collection spots work with paint C
okay to collect and recycle it um so the
amount of money that's put on a can of
paint somewhere between 75 cents and
a135 a gallon is managed by paint care
the only role the state has probably
Dees uh would be to review the plan and
periodically over um again review the
plan and making sure that the program is
working um to the plan but any time that
Dees spends on this is reimbursed
through paint care so there should be no
fiscal note so I guess I'm asking uh if
the committee would give us time to
bring in an amendment for us to look at
and see if we can move this bill forward
yes I um my intention is to have this
bill co go to our subcommittee our solid
waste subcommittee Ed by representative
Murray the folks on that committee are
representative brulard representative
Davis representative kulan
representative Penza representative NAB
representative sofikitis and
representative ger and they will look at
this bill um and discuss different
options and possibly hopefully come up
with a workable Amendment because uh
personally I think this bill has a lot
of Merit um I would love to not see
paint in our
landfills um mixed with kitty litter and
any other stuff so um yeah I'm I'm
hoping that uh our Solid Waste
subcommittee will um we'll take a look
at this representative Bixby yeah so um
a couple things one is that um I think
that uh the solid waste subcommittee
would be happy to uh to uh take
advantage of the work that you've leg
work you've already done uh the other is
that um um one of the things that we uh
should make sure that we include in that
discussion is uh some work with thees to
make sure that the collection mechanisms
in the bill match the collection
mechanisms that we have across the state
already uh because one of the issues
with with just going with model
legislation is sometimes the model
doesn't take into account what's already
on the ground in the state so I think
that um working with the es would uh the
the subcommittee should work with the es
to uh include get their input on on be
best methods in New Hampshire representa
dsy uh yes thank you madam chair yeah
one of the things that I for forgot to
say that um this piece of model
legislation which hopefully we can make
work in in New Hampshire was is very
important to the American codings
Association um because the um paint man
manufacturers do not want to um have 50
different pieces of legislation in in 50
states so they back this legislation
because um they're trying to get it in a
number of states already in New England
it's my understanding that um that it's
in Maine for the the only two states
that don't use this piece of legislation
is Massachusetts and and New Hampshire
so if we could have it uh if if we could
um model this legislation you know to
conform to what's already in what do we
have uh four states yeah four states um
you know then we could move then it's
more of a regional and it works better
for just everybody so I just wanted to
mention that okay thanks yeah thank you
for your work on
that represent B just to clarify one of
the things that I'm thinking about is is
is just in terms of identifying pick uh
the the depositor pickup locations for
the paint and not all states have the
same sort of transfer station system
that we do but the transfer station is
you know if you don't have if the ace
nearest Ace Hardware is 20 miles away
and the transfer station is a mile away
you want to be able to drop at the
transfer station so I just want to make
sure that that sort of um infrastructure
is made use
of represent Murray thank you madam
chair yeah to that point I think that
this is definitely a worthy piece of
legislation to explore um the kitty
litter not only
isn't not an ideal way of disposing
something into our landfills but it's
also adding weight to something that
already exists and so I think if uh we
can as a subcommittee move forward um
and find something workable sounds like
we're very close anyway based on how it
was presented so i' I'd be happy to work
on that okay we just have to be mindful
that our um our bills have to be out of
21st so we have some time to get
something good
together all right any other questions
comments okay so I think we will end our
uh work session this morning for uh
those four bills we have a little bit of
time between now and our first hearing
uh at
10:30 um I do want to um address two
things just
briefly um one is I would remind our
committee members of course not
everybody is here but I so I may have to
say it again um when we have our
hearings I appreciate it if everybody um
refrains from using their cell phones
and texting and please pay attention to
the folks who are testifying who have
come sometimes a very long way to come
and speak with us so just as a matter of
courtesy and the other thing I um wanted
to um
reiterate as this was a something that
was brought up in the last hearing
regarding um state
employees in their official capacity
before any legisl ative meeting or
hearing that yes indeed according to
section 90 RSA 98- Fon one um state
employees and members of um state
agencies do indeed have the right uh to
promote or oppose directly or indirectly
any legislation pending or proposed
before the general court and um that is
something that we should be cognizant
of and with that I will take a little
you
okay okay I'm going to open up the
hearing for HB
1687 relative to disposal of
construction and demolition debris from
State construction projects and I invite
representative
Clutier to introduce this bill good
morning okay good morning Madam chair
members of the ex uh environment and
agriculture committee for the record I
state representative John cluder from
Sullivan County district 6 which
comprises the communities of cin and
Claremont here today in strong support
of House Bill
1687 which would mandate that all state
construction projects include a
requirement that hazardous waste be
separated from construction and
demolition or CND debris at the
construction
prior to transport to a recycling
committee or transfer station I
introduced this bill to strengthen new
hamp's current environmental laws
regarding how we and state government
handle the separation of such waste from
CND D debris generated from State
constru construction projects I believe
that this separation of this way should
be done at the actual construction site
not at any transfer station or recycling
facility off often some distance away
from the construction site as is often
done now by mandating that such
Separation on site we could reduce the
chances of hazardous way environmental
contamination of our air water and land
as well as reduce the amount of time
transfer station or
recycling employees are exposed to this
waste waste which usually contains
according to my understanding some
dangerous substances like Mercury and
past furthermore I if House Bill 1687
becomes law I would believe it would set
a good example for New Hampshire's
political subdivisions counties
municipalities and school districts on
how to more safely handle the separation
of hazardous waste from their
construction and demolition debris
generated by all of their construction
projects in setting a good example state
government should share its best
practice practices in this waste
handling so as to more thoroughly
protect our precious environment as well
as even reduce costs finally I if I
believe this bill becomes law the state
should share these safe separation
practices with private businesses and
nonprofits so as to ensure so as to
encourage them to do a better job in
separating such waste from CND D
debris frankly I mean I'm going to be
all put everybody on my cards on the
table frankly I was inspired to
introduce House Bill
1687 because of a potential
environmental threat in my home
community of Claremont a potential
threat posed by a private waste handling
company or recycling facility called
Acuity management which wants permission
from the City of Claremont to change the
type of recycling materials that his
Claremont site can accept a site close
to many homes businesses and am traks
railroad stations and an elementary
school permission that has so far been
denied by The Claremont Zoning Board of
adjustment this denial is now the
subject of a lawsuit against the City by
Acuity I am concern concerned that if
the city were to lose this lawsuit and
and I'm not I'm not a lawyer so I'm not
sure what their chances are there is
presently no protection from the
possible environmental hazards of of
waste at all and this at least would
guarantee waste from State construction
projects would not be unseparated be
transferred to this facility and another
thing waste that is going to be and I've
been told as many as they want to do 50
trucks a day I'm assume this is which I
was almost fell out of my chair when I
heard this 50 trucks during the week
that could be trucked into A's
Industrial Boulevard site and this has
got my city in an uproar and frankly I
don't know if any anybody in my city
that's that's in favor of the city's
opposed to it and the our entire
Claremont house delegation is opposed to
what they want to do so and I this has
been going on for nearly four years in
fact I remember going to the first
hearing which is held just prior to the
pandemic in in early February of 2020 so
this is an ongoing
issue but I just want to give you some
background so I want to be clear why I'm
doing this but not only for the rest of
the state but for the benefit of my home
community of Claremont in conclusion I'm
more than happy to work with this
committee to improve the bill with
helpful amendments but I would urge you
all eventually to give a positive
recommendation to House Bill 1687 and
thank you very much for listening thank
you representative
cluder uh I I have a quick question um
on line seven in this bill and first of
all does does everyone in the committee
have a copy of the bill because if you
you don't there are copies on the table
over
there um so my question is on line seven
the contract shall include a requirement
that all hazardous material it be
separated is there a definition of what
hazardous material is somewhere well I I
I'll
ad
can you put your mic on
pleasee that I'm still getting used to
these so I am you know there's a bit of
a discrepancy the top page the cover
page of the bill as you read it says
hazardous
waste text says hazardous material again
if this committee wants to straighten
this discrepancy out out and I'm open I
mean I you know hazardous waste hasn't
material I'm I'm very flexible on it but
I am more than willing to work with the
committee with a helpful amendment to
correct this discrepancy so that the
bill is consistent both cover page and
in the actual text I hope that help
answers your question yes thank you
representative marray thank you um Madam
chair um to that end I am curious I
think the department I would like to
hear from them because I do know that
the department defines hazardous
material versus hazardous waste maybe
differently um and so um depending on
those other things but I do have a
question regarding um how you before you
go on so then I would say that at some
point we might want to uh refer to an
RSA that has that definition in this
particular bill I I yes and I not to
debate the substance okay go ahead I'm
sorry I didn't mean to no no no that's
okay I was looking at 149 M Uh I that is
mentioned at the end and I just want to
ensure that that covers the scope of any
of the materials okay sure um but my
other may I yeah um my other question
was whether or not you had envisioned uh
a way to
um how or temporarily sort the items
that would be deemed hazardous on the
construction site it sounds like Source
separation is your goal so I was curious
if you had any thought as to how that
I'll admit not an expert on that
hopefully you know I know Dees which
just here to answer some of your
questions I don't know maybe if there's
any construction people here no matter
how they feel about the bill could give
us some
insight uh but I'm more than happy to if
we have to incorporating the bill what
best practices are I don't maybe it's
more a question of rules uh if this bill
becomes law uh I I'm more than open
because I I the construction people I
think would know how to do it
representative
and I'm I'm I'm not an expert so I'll
just that's my answer so hopefully that
helps representative
Katon uh yes representative thank you
for your testimony for introducing this
important bill uh the implication on
this bill then is that the construction
company transports that separated
material to the appropriate site which
isn't always the same site is that is
that the way I'm reading this
yes as I understand it you know at the
construction site as I understand it
they have the CND debris and it's in
most cases un unseparated and then they
transfer it to a facility that would
handle it and separate it and this is as
I understand what a wants to do in in my
community I I can't speak for all
companies but the concern is in
Claremont that this hazardous Wass and
I've been told as much many as 50 truck
loads a day which again I I find
unbelievable and I'm talking about
during the week would come into
Claremont with CND D debris including
hazardous waste and we are we are
concerned in Claremont that this poses a
danger to our entire Community our homes
our our
businesses uh as I said an elementary
school and an Amtrak railroad station
which is nearby that our our
Junction uh and it it right now they do
handle various Rec recycling materials
but they really want to change the whole
concept of how they run their business
and the city is is adamant opposed
including the Zoning Board of
adjustment uh and and so I am very
concerned about this situation and I'm
trying with this bill to help my city
but also help the the rest of the state
because I'm sure there are other places
communities around the state that have
environmental threats from the way
hazardous waste or Hazard however you
call it is is is separated from cons C
and D debris so I don't know if I've
answered your question but hopefully
some maybe the the department Dees or a
construction person could further
elaborate quick followup representative
kraton okay then representative Bixby
the question still is those 50 trucks
could go to 50 different locations based
carrying I suppose that's possible but
and this is what I'm hearing from from
and I ACU's proposal this is what I've
read in in the in the press as many as
50 which again I find unbelievable
anyway it may not be 50 every day
whatever it is right whatever it is they
go to different locations thank you so
much represent
Bixby so uh couple of things one is
simply a clarification the on the front
page where it says hazardous waste that
is the uh OS analysis it is not actually
part of the bill uh okay but but um
where it's where you have hazardous
material in the bill uh we should have a
uh sighting from the dees statutes to
say to to reference their definition
there um and uh I I think that um one of
the you kind of covered this in your
testimony but I think one of the
important things is that uh the state
projects are going to be a small
fraction of the actual number of
projects out there but I I I think that
um what you have in terms of you know
this could be a model for it could be
Model Behavior if not putting a
requirement of would you think would you
consider having a broader requirement or
would you just want to have this at the
state level a broad broadening the in
scope of the bill yeah to cover what to
Municipal there a part of me that is
open but I just am I am concerned in the
case of Municipal cons their debris
could this be an unfunded mandate under
art article I believe 28a so I'm
concerned about that without the state
paying for it as far as the private
sector I don't know how the private
sector would feel but I'm willing to I
understand the some of the concerns of
private contractors that they are trying
to do various construction projects now
and costs have gone up as we are being a
member of the public works and highways
committee I well aware how much
Construction costs have gone up and as
the chair probably remembers as a member
of the Sullivan County delegation we
struggled with that when the cost of
renovating are went up too so I'm
careful I I well I really am concerned
about I'm both concerned about our
environment but I'm understand of adding
to the cost right now so if we can have
the state become a model and then sh do
share its best practices with our
political subdivisions and our private
sector hopefully we'll all benefit and
hopefully we'll we'll cut cost and also
protect our precious
environment
question yeah representative uh NAB was
first and then we'll go over to you
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question I'm just sort of
trying to understand the underlying
issue and how the bill addresses it if
um the private company in your town got
permission to accept different types of
recycling materials does it matter how
they're sorted at the construction site
or do you still have the same imp of
them being transported to your town so
so thank
you would hope that a and I'm just using
the example that the ACU would bring in
stuff that that is separated from
private but that there's no requirement
that that company do so but this at
least would would any hazardous material
or Haz whatever you call from state
would the hazardous material would have
to be separated before coming to the
Acuity facility if this bill as as I in
written and I intend it becomes law I
mean I would hope the company inity
would would would encourage good
business practices but there is no
requirement when it comes to private
sector construction CND debris right now
or what our municipalities gener I don't
know if that answers your question but I
I'm might consider going farther but I
mean that's up to the Comm too because I
think we we have to proceed slowly at
the moment I so um representative NAB
you may have a followup thank you madam
chair I should have asked that out loud
um so the material would still come to
the facility it would just be separated
like State material State projects you
could still have hazardous materials
come to the facility they just have
would have been separated I mean could
it could it be already separated I I
suppose that's possible uh but I'm
assuming that this m CN D debris is
going to come in you know and its
hazardous part will be unseparated from
the rest of it and they they're supposed
to as I understand their proposal they
Claremont okay um I think representative
gerana then representative Duty and
then oh okay you want you want yeah
thank you
you and you okay just wanted to to offer
a point of information for the committee
uh is that both hazardous waste and
hazardous materials are defined and
distinguished from one another in RSA
B2 um and the the hazardous materials
definition refers then to a set of
federal uh guidelines so it would seem
that that would be a really easy uh
change to make in the bill and it does
seem to be already well defined so if
we're talking about separation of
hazardous materials at the site uh as I
said I I think that would be a pretty
easy determination to make based on
current RSA and the federal guidelines
to which they
refer your clarification
representative representative sopak
kitis um Welcome to our committee I'm
also from another uh Border Town
Nashville so I'm just curious does
Vermont uh I I'm not sure we we and this
you mean you're talking about trash in
general Solid Waste well we we have a a
transfer facility is my understanding
right now the way it's run it only
Claremont residents can use it at at one
time and I don't want to get in this too
much but we had an incinerate at that
took waste from it was a big by state
district but I don't really want to get
into that too much today but right now
any and I'm not talking about
construction and de demolition debris so
much but it's all our waste and it has
to be generated basically by Claremont
residents or businesses you have to have
a sticker to get get in if you want to
actually use the
facility uh but I it's just basically
our transfer station is is for claremon
residents and businesses right now so I
don't know if that answers your question
thank you it's perfect you're welcome
represent dsy thank you madam chair um a
a comment first I I normally park on the
on the third level of the garage and as
I was coming over the walkway I happened
to look down and I think what I was
looking at was a huge dumpster full of
construction debris and and when I
looked at it it was like how do you
separate that I mean it was a mess but I
ALS also have another question that's
okay um in doing your research for the
bill uh did you check out what uh other
New England states are doing and the
reason I'm asking it's been a while
since I went to uh an EBC webinar but
they they do have training sessions on
construction and debris and the last one
I went to I recognize I mean this is a a
big problem especially in Massachusetts
where I think they limit um they limit
the amount of construction and debris so
I know this is going on in a number of
states and if New Hampshire doesn't do
anything we're going to be The Dumping
Ground for all of this because it's a
big
problem I agree we it could be a Dumping
Ground representative uh one thing I
know I haven't looked at how other
states do it to be honest with you I am
you know maybe I should but I'm
concerned right now about our state but
I realize that you might as a committee
study what best practices of other
states and that does remind me I that
I've been told that the the demolition
what is going on with the parking garage
supposedly the state does separate
hazardous materials from their
construction and demolition debris but I
haven't been able to confirm that uh
maybe someone else here so actually they
do do it so I don't think we you know
because we're right next to the
demolition for the parking garage at
least we aren't exposed and I applaud
whoever is doing if they're doing an
environmental correct environmentally
correct manner but we ought to have the
same standards for all of our state uh
and the only other thing I do want to
add supposedly to I have been told that
the city of Lebanon separates has it
from from its CN debris on its own they
are not mandated so that's a example of
one of our political subdivisions
separating but again you this committee
may want to confirm that
so I I think you raised some very good
points and I think thank you very much I
hope I have answered your question
representative
Penza so you sort of just answered my
question um a little bit um in regards
with the state you're you're saying that
um from what you know and if we can
confirm that that would be great um that
they're already doing it on site during
demolition or the legislative only okay
I want to be clear about that you know
and I I can't speak I for other
construction sites I assume they are not
doing it but I you know I don't want to
absolutely say yes or no
question representative k i
was thank you madam
chair I understand this bill and um why
it would be
important but I'm going to look at it um
because I'm looking at uh the RSA that
you referenced in here uh what
construction and demolition debris
means and
and what you're asking of is if someone
is doing a remodeling job they usually
bring in a dumpster on site to um put
that debris into a
container and it's specifically slated
for construction debris if they have to
separate that on site you're asking them
to bring in exponentially 10 to 15
containers and that cost would be
exorbitant um not only to the
homeowner because that's who the cost
would get put on to but these businesses
would not be able to in some of these
locations would not be able to
accommodate that many containers so that
the separation could be done how would
you handle
this okay your your point is well taken
and that's one reason that this bill
targets
uh basically State construction projects
only it does not Target your own local
con of your own uh polit our own
political subdivisions right it does not
and this is the bill as written does not
uh cover private construction projects
you want to remodel your home your
business or any company wants to do
it as as I've written the bill or my
intent of the bill is not to cover this
right now because I think part of it we
got to develop best practices and I
think the state needs to act as a model
for SE such separation of materials from
construction and demolition debris that
is my intent it just applies to State
construction projects and uh that's uh
what what my intent is anyway thank you
for representative Penza I believe you
had a follow-up question did I neglect
to say that I'm
sorry go ahead if you have a follow-up
question to your previous
one so just from having a husband that
works in this space um a lot of the
stuff is already done um on a private
you know just to speak back to what
representative ktas says um you know
when you're even on a private level I
know you're not speaking on a private
level you're talking about state level
so did you realize that there is on on a
private level you you can't just throw
you know you're remodeling something you
can't just throw a whole bunch of stuff
in that dumpster doesn't work like that
so
um you're realizing that piece so you're
talking about maybe specifically those
hazardous materials that representative
gerna was talking about that are very
difficult maybe to separate once it gets
to a location is that the intent of this
bill because it would be hard to
separate well in general just the
materials that might you know are cause
an environmental or health hazard that's
that's the intent whether it's an and
right now I'm trying to focus on the
debris the hazardous material in state
construction projects that's that's my
intent now I don't I can't speak for the
private sector maybe that's good news
that the private sector all a lot of the
con have to follow stringent laws and
regulations but my focus is right now
what is happening at at especially State
construction projects and I think we
need to frankly to strengthen our
Environmental laws in respect to this
area because I as I said I explain what
my constituents may be facing if this
project you know if the company wins
this lawsuit what could be happening and
I want to protect not only the people
the state but my clont representative
K thank you madam chair and in reading
your bill you reference again RSA 149
[Music]
M4 for
d a and it defines what construction and
demolition debris I've seen yeah I've SE
I've read the definition
okay
now when I look at this and if you're
looking at hazardous
materials you're saying that all
everything listed in here would be
considered hazardous
including no am I misunder
misinterpreting no thank
you
representative um was some somebody had
oh yeah representative Howard you had
your hand up before no sorry no okay
representative Murray thank you madam
chair um and thank you to the
representative for taking my question I
just want to be clear that in addition
to physical structure construction sites
we are also through your bill
potentially including Highway
construction road construction I just
want to be clear that what what we're
talking about with State projects uh
that's a good point I mean I did not
clarify so I assume they would apply to
road construction projects as well that
that is
correct represent na thank you madam
chair um this is maybe a naive question
but I'm following up on representative
ktoa is it separating non-hazardous and
hazardous are there further would the
Hazardous Waste be further separated
into different categories my
intent Bill uh would be to separate the
hazardous material from the construction
and Dem and uh and and basically then we
the nonhazardous uh material you know
could be I think what this company wants
to do they want to separate and then
ship out by rail uh the non
non-hazardous material to other
locations around the country too which
is which a point of contention but the
the point is to separate the hazardous
material from the non-hazardous material
in the CND D debris and I just think
think it should be done at the
construction site to save cost to save
exposure to trucks coming into a
community to save the limit the amount
of time that transfer station and
recycling facility employees are exposed
to this hazardous material because
that's we can't get around for they are
going to be exposed but I want to reduce
them and I figure at the construction
site
as okay and just so that we know what
we're talking about um as representative
ger referenced before RSA
um
B2 uh number uh Roman numeral 8 says
hazardous materials means those
substances or materials in such quantity
and form which may pose an unreasonable
risk to health and safety or property
when transported in Commerce by all
modes which may include but are not
limited to explosives radioactive
materials edog Ed logic agents flammable
liquids or solids combustible liquids or
solids poisons oxidizing or corrosive
materials and compressed gases which are
listed by the materials transportation
Bureau of the United States Department
of Transportation in title 49 of the
code Federal Regulations as amended and
there is also in that um
statute a on Roman numeral 7 hazardous
waste means a solid semi-solid liquid or
contained gaseous waste or any
combination of these wastes which
because of their quantity concentration
or physical chemical or infectious
characteristics may cause or contribute
to an increase in mortality and there's
a whole bunch more stuff but we do have
the two separate and distinct
definitions of hazardous waste versus
hazardous materials I think we're
probably with this build talking more
about hazardous materials but I don't
see any reason why we couldn't include a
reference to both sections of this
statute so anyway um any other questions
for representative cluer representative
gerana thank you madam chair uh so and
I'm kind of thinking about something you
just said a moment ago representative
wouldn't this also lead to a more
efficient uh process in the sense that
right I mean we can landfill
construction debris
for example some of our landfills in New
Hampshire with some of our with some of
the um hazardous materials
May likely uh have to be uh sent out of
state so wouldn't it be a more efficient
process to site to separate it on site
and that way you can send construction
debris directly to landfills that accept
construction debris rather than having
to go to an intermediary site where
separation happens and then sending out
materials in different directions from
there yes I agree with you I think that
would be my intent that if if if we do
this right and I talked about best
practices we could maybe more
effectively and economically separate
such material because part of I not only
to protect our precious environment but
to reduce cost and so I I would agree
with you that that's the intent and I
believe we we dealt with this issue way
back in 2007 where I think we considered
and passed a bill under then Governor
Lynch to to ban the burning of CN D
debris I'm as I understand it I vaguely
remember so we've dealt with this before
and I want to go
further because uh we we've I think got
a landfill it now any we can't burn it
anymore according to my understanding
thank you very much any other
questions thank you very much
representative cluder I appreciate you
introducing this bill this morning thank
you madam chair member members of the
committee and I'm looking to call Katie
lejoy from Charlestown good morning and
agriculture uh good morning uh my name
is Katie lejoy I live in Charlestown I'm
a nurse um I urge you to support this
bill and um I've been en closed for the
public record and for uh distribution
among committee members uh two copies of
a report from a Governor's commission
that focused on um construction and
Demolition and this commission was back
in
2011 and um I had the honor of being
part of that commission and helped write
this report I think you're going to find
a lot of answers to your questions um in
the
report uh one of the big things I just
want to point out when we're looking at
what could be possibly in construction
and demolition debris that is haard is
certainly lead based
paint huge one um and we don't want that
just coming into Claremont as uh
representative cluer
said um I believe this morning you each
got an email with uh the web link to
this report uh that I'm going to give
you and um I also included a page from
another report that uh has a duplicate
graph of what's in the bigger report and
um the that one is a colored graph that
talks about how um uh Recycling and
waste reduction can um keep landfills
the open for a longer time um proper
management of CN D protects us all and
uh this is an important bill and I urge
you to support it
thank you so much thank you any
questions from the committee um thank
you seeing none I appreciate and if you
have anything to hand out please U pass
it by over there thank you by uh
representative sofikitis
next I'd like to call um John Tut Hill
from my hometown of
aworth good morning re um Mr Tod Hill
welcome to environment and agriculture
morning Madam chairman um members of the
committee it's pleasure to be here I'll
be very brief I did uh submit u a letter
with a copy actually of the 2011
commission report um and I think
listening to the discussion
today um it's clear to me that probably
this bill is going to need more study um
I support the bill the intent is is very
good and it is something that has been
looked at for years but New Hampshire
has not quite yet arrived at the point
where we are
discouraging um adequately mixed loads
of waste um and that applies not just to
construction and demolition waste but to
all waste I mean it's sort of like the
garbage can under your kitchen sink um
if it's got paper in it and aluminum
cans in it and you dump a you know a
load of bacon grease and some coffee
grounds on it the entire entire uh Bin
of of valuable materials is basically no
longer available and that's the same
with construction and demolition debris
bins
um we always used to refer to it as the
transfer station is the bin of Last
Resort when you didn't know where to put
something when it was maybe problematic
um that's where you went and and that
creates a lot of problems this is why in
Sullivan County and in Claremont there
is so much concern about a company that
is
proposing uh in in applications to Dees
a 500 to 800 ton per day facility taking
in in uh bins basically dumping them on
a on a pad um pulling out perhaps some
you know steel or high value materials
to some extent on a very small site and
then loading it into train cars for
shipment I believe in The Proposal that
Dees is now rejected from
2019 um I think it was actually
technically rejected in 20120 as an
administrative decision um but shipping
in train cars out to Ohio were at the
time disposal fees were around $17 a ton
what's happened in New Hampshire since
the commission report is that uh there's
a large company in eping for example
that is doing a lot of processing and
they as a private company can set their
gate fees uh high enough for mixed loads
that contractors uh are not going to
bring in mixed loads that it becomes
cost effective to do Source segregation
on site um this is the same thing that
the city of Lebanon did which pretty
much dried up um the tonnage arriving at
their facility which was using up
landfill space and had toxic um well
issues with toxic uh materials which
were impacting their leech a impacting
their costs and when when that material
was processed there was enough toxic
loading um in what are called the fines
or what's left over after processing
that it no longer met the standards for
using as alternate daily cover at
landfills which is a a common use for
the residuals from the process C and D
streams so what the bill I think really
is intending to do and it it really is
sort of a model because it is only
affecting State contracts for putting
out to bid so everybody's on a Level
Playing Field where you know a
contractor is not going to come in to
knock down a building like the doj
building next door um next
door um and you know everybody's going
to going to have to consider this in
putting together their bid package that
we're going to do Source segregation yes
yes there is some more labor yes there
are some more bins there's some
management um but in the long run um
well some of the upfront costs may be
more expensive I think that you are
actually benefiting the state um in a
number of ways and hopefully at some
point and this is why I think maybe some
study would be a good idea we can look
at ways to expand this uh out into the
marketplace and the private sector uh
and to help municipalities do more
Source segregation so that at a transfer
station in a small town like ours with a
a very minimal budget you you're not
simply just throwing everything into one
bin and creating an expensive mess so
I'll leave it at that for now and um I'm
I'm glad that you're taking up this
issue and I do support the bill but I
think probably it is going to need some
work in terms of definitions and and how
we sort of fit it into the state
Contracting process thank you represent
Bixby you yeah so um the you you
mentioned that you think it might need
more study but I'm wondering if the more
study would be what's necessary in order
to expand it Beyond State projects and
if uh simply doing a little bit of
clarification in terms of uh what we
mean by hazardous waste by referencing
the right rsas would turn this into a
good bill uh as to to start the process
and uh start providing that model rather
than spending another year trying to
study it to get it perfect
I would welcome that approach
representative so thank you yes
representative
fenza I am perplexed that this isn't
already the case because in a sense if
if you're not separating hazardous ways
based upon what you said you're
contaminating everything else correct
yes and then when it goes to the
facility you're then um putting all of
those people that are now you know
whatever separating that waste all those
workers at risk as well but even of
course the travel and all of those types
of things um would you feel that I mean
do we even have an idea of what's going
on right now a picture besides I know
this is brought up because of a specific
issue in a region where this is at
because this just seems perplexing that
this wouldn't already be the case well I
mean there have been some materials
representative such as asbestos uh
mercury in some cases which are
regulated and
well uh New Hampshire does require
demolition permits that's put back to
the municipal level so you know towns
under a thousand administratively that's
simply not being followed up on so we
still do see quite a lot of mixed waste
going through the system I think the
economic incentive is the important one
but it's not strictly necessary and the
proposal for example in Claremont um
just the economics of it you know
basically encourage us to continue with
past bad practices of mixing wastes
dumping loading and shipping away uh in
this case out to very large landfills in
Ohio where people are not necessarily
supportive of that that
process followup followup um so would
you as a gauge for people that are
working at um you know at landfills at
transfer stations um the workers that
are dealing with this day in and day out
um they would support something like
this probably that would need to be a
little tightened up cleaned up broader
because I think it should be for you
know this should apply for private State
everybody should have the same playing
field right I think we need to get there
yes okay thank you representative Murray
thank you madam chair and this question
may not be for you and if it's not then
I'll direct it either to the prime
sponsor or the department but I I I was
curious about uh the RFP process um
since their state run projects and would
a disposal or uh any sort of requirement
plan for disposal be required in rfps
that go out um that's sort of a question
I had if there was any thought around
that um I don't know much about that
actually but I think there is pretty
standard language in in many um rfps and
in contracts for how waste is going to
be managed it's usually pretty simple
that you're just going to follow all
laws and
regulations
um I I think it's been interesting
watching the doj project next door
because they are doing Source
segregation I don't think that that was
required and yet I've watched University
projects where dormitories are being
just just knocked down and the entire
load just you know excavators dumping it
right into bins those are mixed loads
those are potentially contaminated loads
those are the kind of things we don't
want to see coming into Claremont
because they can do it cheaply there so
again if you had across the board
regulation um everybody's basically
bidding on the same project I've talked
to people working for large Contracting
companies like uh
Dew um and they said yeah you know we
we're prepared to do that and if if a
client wants that we will do that but we
cannot compete if we're going up against
companies that are simply doing tear
downs and
shipping okay followup I guess to my
point I guess that was my thought was
maybe another Approach at this is
requiring that Source separation in
statute somewhere for All State projects
that that is clearly enumerated in that
process somewhere in addition to the
other things that the prime sponsor is
looking for yeah yeah Contracting is way
outside of my realm thanks okay thank
you representative Howard thank you
madam chair um if this I I I think that
this bill should be expanded to Beyond
just the state projects otherwise it's
almost completely ineffective because
what would compel a profit driven
contract to um follow a model that was
that would probably add expenses to it
so um I guess my question or I'm not
sure there's a question in there but um
do you agree with me that it's would be
less almost ineffective to do just a
model program um I think it's somewhat
symbolic but I also think it's important
for the state to be showing that it is
um committed to acting responsibly um
and setting up a model so I I think is
uh representative Bixby said perhaps you
you start small and and I think there's
so much work being done right now in New
Hampshire on the solid waste issue on a
developing policy that yeah this is a
sort of a dynamic and we're in a moment
of opportunity right now we haven't seen
for 20 years so you know I think we need
to keep working forward on
this any other
questions thank you Mr Tut Hill
appreciate your time
today I call Todd pisit from New
good
morning good morning Madam chair members
of the committee for the record my name
is Todd pisit with the New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services
hazardous waste management Bureau and
I'm joined by Michael Nork who's also
with Dees but he's with the solid waste
management Bureau so he can ask Solid
Waste specific answer solid way specific
questions um there's been a lot said
here today first of all just just to be
clear on the the definitions between
hazardous waste and hazardous materials
hazardous waste is something that is a
waste already so it has to be a waste
before it's a hazardous waste um and
there are very specific
definitions uh requirements to to make
something a hazardous waste as opposed
to a solid waste hazardous materials is
more of a
do um definition it has to do with
things that are transported over the
road ways and that can include products
that are not
waste uh importantly hazardous waste
does not include things like asbest and
pcbs because they are regulated on their
own
individually so things those are common
things at at at uh construction and
demolition sites asbest and uh
pcbs but to be clear uh the
representative over here I didn't C your
name
um everything that this bill is looking
to do is already in Rule and statute the
Hazardous Waste rules that at New
Hampshire administrative rules EnV hw100
through 1300 require any business or
government entity that generates waste
they're required to evaluate whether
that waste is hazardous and if it's
hazardous waste it needs to be kept
separate on site managed very
specifically labeling containers safety
security and then transported on a
manifest to a facility that is permitted
to receive that either a transfer
facility where it can be put on into
another truck or a hazardous waste
Transfer uh a tsdf a transfer storage
and disposal facility so if it's
hazardous waste is generated on a site
it needs to be separated out and shipped
proper ly and disposed of properly there
are no tdfs in New Hampshire so anything
that can't uh be disposed of in New
Hampshire has to go out of state ASB
bestus doesn't fall on that but if you
had a dumpster full of uh demolition
debris on a site and as bestus got into
that dumpster the entire dumpster is as
bestus contaminated material and would
have to it would be cost prohibitive for
a a demolition company to do that so I I
don't think that um I I think that
everything this bill is trying to
accomplish already happens but I I may
be I may be reading the bill incorrectly
but I think that the bill is just adding
one sentence to an already existing
statue and it is basically saying that
when a state contract for demolition is
engaged in that that contract needs to
say that that that those hazardous
materials need to be separated on site
again that's already required to be done
but I think adding that language to a
contract just helps with compliance with
exist represent
Penza thank you so much for clarifying
that would you be willing to work with
the sponsor of this bill um because if
this is about a contract that they have
that seems as if it's a little bit
imminent um that this cont contractor
could be told that this contract
violates you know state law right I I I
I'd be happy to um Madam chair you you
mentioned earlier something about when
you read the definitions of the rules
you suggested maybe we could add
hazardous waste and and I hadn't thought
about that but it might make sense to
just change that line to say anyone who
generates waste must separate hazardous
waste and hazardous materials again
that's just sort of off the cuff I
haven't thought about that but
yeah I I I believe I would um amend this
to say hazardous waste or and or
hazardous
materials because I mean clearly either
of those things could occur uh when
you're uh in the middle of demol you
know demolishing a building right or
structure whatever representative Howard
thank you madam chair um so you said
that the these rules already exist and
that's across the whole span of of state
public contracts to private contracts
yes yeah any any business or government
entity that generates waste must
determine whether that waste is
Katon thank you madam chair thank you
for testimony and clarifying I'm
just so it's already in statute yes
and rules and
rules so even if we added waste Andor
material all we're doing is directing
that it's in the contract right the way
I read this the way I read this bill
it's just changing contract language
it's not requiring something new to be
done it's just changing contract
language that in my opinion might
improve compliance with the already
existing rules okay thank you so much
okay represent Bixby all right so um it
sounds like uh on on one level this has
already been covered but uh do would you
support the bill going forward as a way
of uh improving compliance uh for
something that's already in rules well I
I haven't talked to the commissioner
about whether or not DS would support or
or not support anything but personally
that's my opinion that that uh
compliance could improve if that
language is in
contract and uh a followup followup so
uh there was uh so the the the bill just
aims at State contracts but if the rules
already cover private contracts do you
think it would make sense to expand the
bill to cover private to required in
private contracts or would that be
opening up a a nest of possible
complications that would yeah I'd have
to look at the bill again but my my
understanding
is that the bill is is just amending an
already existing RSA and I don't know
how complicated we want to get with
amending that RSA go ahead I just wanted
to add that the the RSA that this amends
is uh directed at Department of
administrative services so it would it
would only govern the contracts that
department of administrative Services is
responsible for um so making an
amendment that covers businesses
probably wouldn't fit with the the
overall uh content of that statute
follow up so uh just we we heard
testimony that um that there was the
that the doj product is Project is being
very well done and that some University
projects have not been as well done
would the department of of uh would
would the department of administrative
Services be overseeing those University
division um thank you uh representative
Bix for the question I think it's a
question of whether the department uh is
providing oversight at the site of
generation of the waste is that is that
a fair characterization of your
question so is essentially um it has to
more to do with uh how broad the
department of administrative Services
reach over things that are state or
state related is so
would you would univers would the State
University system fall under that their
purview or would that be a separate
thing that would need a separate it need
to be in a separate section of law thank
you for clarifying yeah that's a good
question I I did before this hearing
just look at RSA I believe it's RSA
21 I forgot what the what the uh 21i 21i
thank you um and it does specifically
call out the State University system in
kind of the introduction Rory language
with that
statute and I just like to follow up on
on that question that the example that
was given about a what a dormatory
that's just being demolished before any
building is demolished they're required
to file a permit with the air Resources
Division of Dees that um that they're
required to inspect for things like as
Festus so I I can't speak much further
to that because I'm not in the air
Resources Division but there is a
process for evaluating as best as be
demolished okay um representative Penza
and then
Duty so just a quick question back to
the bill so um so there would have to be
another RSA put in here because the RSA
that is specific to that that is talking
about those specific contracts are just
underneath one area and under four state
construction so because I'm saying it
does make sense to have both you know
private and state in here because it's
already in um it's already in rules but
this would have to be Rewritten because
it's only talking about one specific
statute
correct that's that's my understanding
that this wouldn't um this would only
apply to State
contracts follow up follow up um my
other question was about you um stated
with resources how you have to before a
demolition I know just a tiny bit about
this so it's way more than just Aus any
sort they have to evaluate any sort of
hazardous materials that could be in
that building to include you know with
bricks and lead and all okay right I I
was just using asbest as an example
there's oil tanks in the basement they
need to all that needs to be taken care
of Representative
Duty chair uh so uh does your division
of EDS um Dees uh belong to the
environmental Business Council and do
you attend those meetings uh with their
um construction debris
subcommittees we have members uh we have
employees who attend EBC uh meetings but
I don't I don't think Mike does do you
yeah in the solid waste Bureau we do
have some staff that do monitor those
events and and participate or have
participated in the past okay just
follow yeah could you speak um I I was
really um delighted when I saw this bill
because in the 5 years this is my sixth
year that I've been here I don't think
we've had any bills on construction
debris and um you know I I'll just give
you an example I uh chair of the nashwa
Conservation Commission and we've been
trying to get rid of railroad ties for
three years um the railroad ties were
used in the 1970s to you know create a
trail and and they um and I mean it's
been I mean they're still sitting there
and we think we have someplace that'll
take it and yada yada yada so I mean and
and having attended some of those EBC um
meetings um I mean it it just seems to
me like this is a huge issue in New
England um and if New Hampshire doesn't
start to get ahead of it um we are and I
think we already are The Dumping grounds
I think um representative cluer what he
was alluding to in Claremont is
basically a private company that is
accepting construction debris from
probably out of state okay and disposing
of it or or managing it somehow in in
the Claremont area so could you um while
you're here just speak to that broader
issue so the committee might be uh able
to understand better what our role could
be in the
future uh thank you representative Duty
for the question I I'm happy to to
address that to some degree I I
think uh
you know there are obviously challenges
with Solid Waste Management in the state
of New Hampshire construction and
demolition debris is no no exception um
and I believe there was a testimony
previously saying that there are
facilities in New Hampshire that have
been developed to encourage diversion of
solid of uh construction and demolition
debris so facilities like the one in
eping uh that takes in construction and
demolition debris but also separates out
certain components to be recycled or
reused for for uh you know to to avoid
disposal in the landfill to the extent
possible um you know that's something
that I think the department can say we
would like to see more of that activity
happening across the state but we need
more infrastructure to make that happen
so um you know there's definitely
opportunities to increase recycling of
construction and demolition debris uh
but that also comes with challenges so I
hope that that sort of addresses your
so as I understand this particular um
um
requiring State contracts through this
department of administrative Services
statute um
to uh separate hazardous waste hazardous
mat material if we wanted to expand this
out to
require not only state but Municipal and
County projects we would have to go to
another part of Statute to possibly
insert language to do
that I I'm not I believe so but I'm not
I'm not 100% sure okay I guess that's
something we'll have to I would just add
or somebody yeah I'm not clear that
there is a state statute that governs
contracts for counties or even just the
private sector I'm not aware think there
are
actually yeah yeah anyway just thinking
out loud thank
you any other questions or
comments no okay thank you I appreciate
your
time and um anybody else in our audience
like to speak on this
bill seeing none I'm going to close the
public hearing on
1687 and we are a bit early
um so I I guess um I don't know if we
can talk about anything in
particular representa Bixby okay so I'd
like to take a second to brag oh go
ahead and go brag um so I was at the uh
NOA winter conference this past weekend
and uh I was presented with an award by
the by NOA New Hampshire for uh being
the uh policy maker of the Year
congratulations um I'm I'm kind of
that we don't have anything else till
one
o'clock um so I guess go have a good
later
now
you
good good afternoon everyone welcome to
environment Agriculture and we will open
up this afternoon with our hearing for
HB
1132 relative to permits for the
sighting of new
landfills and here to introduce the bill
is representative mamila good afternoon
and welcome good afternoon Madam chair
and good afternoon esteemed members of
the committee I'm representative Linda
massamilla and I represent Grafton
one um thank you for giving me this
opportunity uh HB
1132 is easy to support because the bill
fills the Gap in our states already
existing Brownfield incentive
programs it will help ensure the future
that future landfill development is
cited in places with the potential to
minimize negative impacts on the
environment public health and the
quality of
life it is wholly consistent with the
Department's mission statement and
consistent as well with the goals set
put for put forth in the recent
published Solid Waste plan to help
preserve as much land as possible that
is still in a pristine
State this bill will also work hand and
glove with other landfill permit
application requirements under the
Department's existing rules including
the requirement for an applicant to
identify and evaluate alternative sites
that minimize Wetlands
disruption the bill will have no fiscal
impact on Dees or our state or local
governments and no impact at all on
prices paid by state residents for Solid
Waste Management
Services HB
1132 will have a minor impact at most on
the sources a landfill developer must
devote to all of the filing requirements
for permanent application to new
landfills what this bill doesn't do it
does not require a landfill applicant to
build on a Brownfield site it merely
requires a landfill permit applicant
that wants to develop Greenfield sites
to First identify suitable Brownfield
sites that may be reasonable a
reasonable substitute for the applicants
preferred
site our state already has a number of
Brownfield incentive programs designed
to encourage the Redevelopment of
contaminated properties of various kinds
these programs such as the Brownfield
Assessment program the cleanup revolving
Loan Fund and the US government's EPA
direct grant program offers incentive
and support for Reviving Brownfield
sites although HB 11302 establishes a
new filing requirement it is similar and
complementary to the existing Wetland
alternative site evaluation procedure
that landfill applicants are required to
complete
now the F the definition for Brownfield
in our RS a
147 DF colon 3 says brownfields mean
properties which have been
environmentally contaminated subject to
the limitations of RSA 147 F colon 4 the
federal government's definition which
could be included defines them as real
property the
expansion Redevelopment or reuse of
which may be complicated by the presence
of
potential um hazardous substances
pollutants or
contaminants this bill is wholly
consistent with the Department's mission
statement which
declares Dees will help to sustain a
high quality of life for all citizens by
protecting and restoring the environment
and the public health in new New
Hampshire the protection and wise
management of the state's environment
are the main goals of this
Agency New landfills that can be located
on Brownfield sites would both protect
and restore the environment in public
health in New Hampshire it will help
protect by ensuring that new landfills
will not be located in pristine
environments unless it is necessary to
do so and it will help restore it by
steering landfill developers to
Brownfield locations that are already
polluted but ripe for
cleanup according to the dees
website there are approximately 300
Brownfield sites that have been
identified in New Hampshire with several
over a 100 acres and one over a thousand
in
size though the majority are 1 to 10
acres some may have larger adjacent
Parcels of land that are available and
suitable for
development HB
1132 carries no fiscal impact for the
state or local governments or to
Dees if there are any costs to
applicants for from considering
brownfields over Greenfield sites they
would be minor in fact they may even be
offset by the value added to the
applicant from considering the PO
potential development on a Brownfield
site for example the site could be much
cheaper as a
landfill the upside of considering
Brownfield sites for other purposes such
as solar arrays could offer unrealized
Revenue potential for sites that are
as a matter of
policy we as legislator legislators
should prefer that Brownfield sites be
considered for landfills or alternative
projects like solar arrays instead of
using Green Field sites our state's
economy thrives in large part on the
outdoor recre recreational opportunities
that come from having as much pristine
environment as we have our residents
demand and deserve to have their health
and quality of life protected we owe
this to the environment to ourselves and
especially to Future
Generations thank you thank you
representative massila
um now do first of all do you have
written copy of your okay my uh comp
printer broke so I'll take my so she can
take
that afterwards I have a question though
in so far as like how would this work
because as far as I
understand um somebody buys a piece of
land and decides they want to make a
landfill out of it and maybe applies for
a permit and goes through whatever the
process is
so at what point would would the state
then be asking them to use a different
piece of land which they would have to
purchase what would happen is it would
be part of the process they already have
to if there's a Wetlands involved they
have to go through a particular
procedure when they're um going to site
land near uh a landfill near wetlands
and this would just be similar procedure
only now you're looking at Brownfield
sites um like I said the dees does list
what the Brownfield sites are and
therefore they could utilize that
information to find out if it would be
suitable for their
project okay representative ktoa thank
you madam chair and thank you so much
for being here
um I have basically two questions the
first one is is what is the typical
acreage of a landfill site
currently um that's a very good question
and I'm I'm I've got some people behind
me that can give you more detailed
information hey thank
you representative Howard thank you
madam chair um I have two questions too
so um do brownfields typically require
mitigation I can't hear you sorry I'm
sorry do do uh brownfields typically
require mitigation before they're used
for other purposes um I'm not again I'm
not sure I'll defer to the people
because I'm just wondering if if that
would add to the expense of a land
landfill site if they have to mitigate
it first um I I understand that that you
would want to use a Brownfield in order
to um take advantage of the fact that
it's already polluted but I just wonder
if there depending on what the pollution
is I wonder if it needs to be mitigated
the other one is um do they are they
typically near Urban centers are there
what typically near Urban
centers um we have a Brownfield site in
Littleton
uh unfortunately it's close to the amk
river but um I don't know I can't tell
you whether it is or not I can only
speak from my personal
experience representative ger thank you
madam chair thank you representative
Mass Miller for uh presenting this bill
to us um and for taking my question I
I'm wondering and this may be a question
that is better directed toward some of
the folks from Dees but I'm wondering if
you know if we were to consider
Brownfield sites for where a landfill
would go if this would complicate in any
way our ability to monitor potential
leaks for example from a landfill uh in
terms of you know there being underlying
contaminants that would come up uh in
tests and could complicate the process
and and what comes to my mind is for
example some right now question about
some uh uh chemicals that are leaking
into the am usk right out of Bethlehem
and and this is as a result of the fact
that we put aligned landfill over right
the previous unlined landfill that had
existed so that's creating some
confusion because then when we look at
some of the seepage into the river
there's this question of well is that
the current landfill that is leaking or
is that the result of residual chemicals
from the previous unline landfill so I'm
wondering if you know if we put a
landfill on top of a Brownfield site
does do it raise
potential issues around being able to
adequately deter you know monitor
potential uh seepage or leaks in the
future that's a very good question um I
would assume that if a a new landfill
was going to be put in on top of an old
landfill site because it would be modern
more up to date um the liners would be
more in aign with what is expected now
that that problem would be taken care of
as far as the old landfill I would
assume there would have to be some sort
of monitoring either V Via de uh Dees or
the landfill developer thank you very
much representative Murray thank you
madam chair for taking my question and
thank you representative for also taking
my question um so I'm curious to know um
I know that uh and maybe this again is a
question for the Department
but um that many of our Brownfield sites
have oversight with federal agencies as
well so I was just
curious how this would like interact
with that
relationship I I would assume but I'm
not sure so like you said Dees can
probably answer this better than me I
would assume there would be some federal
um oversight that would supersede the
states but I'm not sure
okay representative H Haskins thank you
madam chair and thank you representative
for taking my question I'm assuming too
that the mitigation process would
involve um history with
other um sites that have been
redeveloped and there may even be some
federal money involved to do that but
the mitigation should take care of what
the representative's question was um
that the applicant would be responsible
for I would tend to agree with that
thank
you any other questions represent
Duty um did you have uh Dees input into
the
bill
no any uh the the reason I ask I mean
first of all regarding Brown sites I
mean we have brown we have Brownfield
sites all over the place I mean I think
Nashville has probably I don't know 24
they build houses on them um and I'm not
joking about that but I mean the fact of
the matter is is that developers do come
in and they create a mitigation plan for
the area that has been contaminated and
then they you know and they build around
it um but you know one of the things
that I see with this and I think other
people have raised it is that there's
although it looks like a great solution
I think there's a lot of underlying
Maybe economic um issues that would have
to be uh maybe in rule making uh so I
think it's really important for us to be
able to get some feedback from Dees on
how they perceive this I I agree but I
think that this is just another tool in
the permit application process that Dees
can then factor in to the permit release
and I think that the more knowledge you
have the better it is for the developer
for the department and also for the
people who are going to be affected by
it representative
Howard in the implementation of this
bill is there any way to is there any
reward or incentive to take to choose
Brown site over your original Green site
um like I said there are programs
available through the federal government
and through the state that offer
incentives and help support exploring
Brownfield
sites any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you so much
for coming and introducing the Bill
thank you all for your time and for
listen our questions appreciate okay I'm
calling Tom
Tower to come speak about this
bill
welcome
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee uh before I speak about
11:32 I just wanted to uh speak to the
committee in general and just thank you
over the last number of years there's
been uh a lot of discussion in relation
to Solid Waste in relation to pasas and
certainly a lot of discussion around out
ofate waste and four or five years ago
these issues were certainly were not top
of mind for the State of New Hampshire
uh but they are now and and they are
largely because of the the efforts of
this group so regardless of what side of
the aisle that you're on regardless of
how you voted in these proposed bills
over the last number of years I've seen
a very functional committee work very
hard to listen to what's going on across
the state and to try to reach some level
of compromise in the best interest of
the State of New Hampshire so on behalf
of certainly the group that I represent
which is ncbc for the record my name is
is Tom Tower I reside in Whitefield New
Hampshire Mr Tower could you please tell
us what NC ABC stands for thank you
madam chair it stands for North Country
Alliance for balanced change my uh
formal testimony has been uploaded
online and I am just going to speak at a
very high level to many of the things
that representative massamilla just
spoke about so the first thing that I'll
mention is
um when you look at call it solid waste
sites or or brown fields and we look at
as an example
now what's happened this morning with
the discussion in relation to uh
hazardous materials hazardous
waste um there never ever should be a
consideration for a green field landfill
all other efforts need to be explored in
order to not uh put these hazardous
chemicals into the ground anywhere
that's considered a green field right
green fields are at a premium green
fields are something that we need to
protect representative Masa Miller spoke
about the the the mission of the
department around protecting health and
the environment and that's what we
should be doing first and foremost so
Brownfield uh Brownfield sites are just
an option as what was described earlier
for the Department to put in place some
mechanism so that a a prop a potential
landfill uh uh proposal right a proposal
for new landfill is actually considering
just like they would Wetlands
implications that they consider an
alternate site that includes a site that
is basically already in essence very
limited to what it can provide the site
can be revitalized if used as a as a
landfill it could bring value if used as
a landfill so in essence that's really
what this is all about is is to ensure
one that Greenfield sites are not
considered for these you know hazardous
facilities now and there's a lot of
debate on what you know hazardous
actually means and the definition was
debated this morning but these sites
once they are cited as landfills will in
essence be considered a Brownfield and
for all intent and purposes be almost a
dead site excuse me to do anything
else um
there are some examples of of where this
has been considered uh there is a uh a
uh a landfill developer now that's
looking to revitalize a site in
Massachusetts uh in Hardwick it's a
Brownfield site and what better place to
site a landfill than what was a
previously cited landfill if there's an
opportunity of course all the other
things that are considered um those are
the places that should be considered at
least part of the process right now that
that is not part of the process and so
what this Bill is saying and I'm sure we
can debate it you guys will debate it
all day long it may not be perfect but
it needs to be considered because right
now Green Field sites for landfills is
just wrong and I'm happy to take any
questions
Penza s just trying to think of the
process piece of this
so so usually when um from my knowledge
when someone is putting in uh a a permit
application um at that point they
haven't necessarily purchased let's say
the Green Field Land right yeah so um
they have to you know do a lot of work
but then you know have to justify and
there's a lot of different things that
have to be so how would underneath our
current landfill process which is in a
sense private
ownership would Dees be able to through
this bill I want to make sure that it's
doing its say hey there are six sites
here that are an opportunity for uh you
to look at is is that what you're
thinking that this could possibly do
that we take the massive amounts of
brown sites here in New Hampshire and or
Brownfield sites and say
these are possibly an option would you
indirect a a private permitter to to
look at them thank you for the question
representative um I I think as as part
of the process it it wouldn't be
necessarily direct them but as part of
the permit application that that would
be one of the boxes that that they would
need to check off and that they have
previously evaluated a Brownfield site
as a potential site for the landfill
right now nobody's looking at that why
shouldn't we be looking at them if we've
got over a hundred across the state of
New Hampshire I'm I'm sure they're all
there for various reasons they should be
examined anyway before we ever put a
shovel in the ground to destroy a
Greenfield
site representative
Duty uh thank you madam chair um based
on your knowledge of
brownfields uh is there already I would
I would expect but I don't know isn't
there already a lot of data uh regarding
that site that has to be created when
they're um when they want to look at the
you know Brownfield and figure out
what's there so I would assume that
anybody wanting to purchase that land
for a landfill would already be ahead of
the game is that correct or not do you
have any knowledge on that thank you for
the question representative um I I don't
have specific knowledge knowled but I
would think that there would be a
significant amount of knowledge in
regard to that site there are supposed
to be mechanisms in place for monitoring
those sites for for years and years to
come because of the nature of of the
fact that they're brown fields to begin
with so the data should be there and I'm
thinking if you're a Brownfield site
owner and you got somebody knocking at
the door saying I'd like to buy this I I
would jump on that pretty
quickly representative Howard it seems
like if we if we were to um just put
this bill forward as it is which I I
think it's a great idea I like you know
it makes perfect sense if we were to put
it forward as it is with no carrot or
stick it I could see people going
through the motions and going back to
the Green Field that they had their eye
on in the first place so um is there any
way to add a little bit more heft to
this yeah thank you for the question I I
think it's a a great
question
um just want to be as as delicate as
possible but you know if this becomes
part of the permit application process
then I would think that there would be
mechanisms to ensure that that diligence
was done and it wasn't just an exercise
and checking off the box to your
question how do you call it strengthen
those mechanisms I can't answer that off
the top of my head but if you give me
some time I'll go back and think about
it and get back to you representer ger
thank you very much Madam chair uh and
and actually kind of building off um
representative Howard's question you
know would would one way of of
addressing that issue be to require a a
permit applicant to provide to to say
this is the brown field we looked at and
these are the reasons why it is not
sufficient for our purposes right so
some level of uh putting a burden on the
applicant to demonstrate that they've
considered a site and to explain why
that site's not
adequate thank you for the question and
statement representative um I think
representative masassa Miller spoke
about the process around
Wetlands Wetlands has been heightened to
the extent that they are some of the
most protected areas within the state
although it doesn't necessarily mean you
can't put a a a a landfill anywhere near
them but you need to go through a pretty
extensive process to ensure that those
have been considered I would think that
you you would use a very similar
mechanism to do the same thing with
Brownfield sites thank you any other
questions oh representative H Haskins
thank you madam chair and um thank you
for taking my question I like the idea
of the carrot and stick and I think
we've gotten some information about that
just so far in the testimony in other
words the carrot is this might be much
less expensive and it also might it not
be less controversial when you take a
dead site or a brown field Feld that a
community is not particularly happy with
and mitigate it redevelop it
economically is that not going to be a
plus for the
community thank you for that statement
and question representative H Haskins
absolutely I mean that's one of the
benefits is that you've got a site right
now that in essence is for all intents
and purposes dead to revitalize that
that will generate income and uh
represent an infusion of cash to a
community that might be in dire need of
of that Revenue absolutely but certainly
not at the expense of a green space yeah
followup followup thank you um I'm also
thinking that communities have a lot of
interest in what happens with these
sites and I know something about this
coming from the Sea Coast we've had our
own issues with this and
permitting was very much delayed for
years I'm thinking that if this process
were to be an economic um Advantage for
the community you'd have Community buyin
instead of having you know people going
to sue you all the time and elongate the
process you'd have people saying yes
thank you let's do this let's improve
our community would it not I absolutely
agree yes thank you representative
Penza
oh I'm sorry sopus I thought you raised
your hand oh okay um as someone who's
been
intimately um involved in the northern
country I would just like to say that I
think this is brilliant absolutely
brilliant and it um it takes in a lot of
the missing pieces and so I'd be
delighted to help work with this and um
I commend you representative for this
Bill thank you very much representative
representative
Penza I know this bill is speaking to a
specific area in regards with
brownfields and citing new
landfills but in a sense couldn't we put
this in kind of the realm of all of
those like for this would be fantastic
for transfer stations this would be um
fantastic for recycling centers because
they're not necessarily digging into the
ground
that's not an issue um even for you know
like what conquer's doing with
incinerating this I I mean I know that
they would probably have to change and I
know that this is specific but would you
think you know could we put it into the
whole realm of what we're trying to do
here with um with our waste in New
Hampshire thank you representative I
think it's an excellent idea in my
hometown at Whitefield the transfer
station is the Oldtown landfill so that
site in essence dead but functions you
know very well as a transfer station
today but yeah I think that's an
excellent
idea any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you Mr Tower
thank you committee I'd like to call
Sarah us ask
Kim New Hampshire Dees good afternoon
and
welcome
good afternoon Madam chair and members
of the committee for the record my name
is Sarah uos Kern and I serve as the
assistant director of the waste
management division at the New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services and
with me I have Leah McKenna the
administrator of the solid waste
management Bureau at
Dees Dees absolutely values revitalized
izing Brownfield sites and we have a
vibrant brownfields program that has
been around for almost 30 years and has
leveraged funding uh to investigate and
mitigate contamination at hundreds of
sites in the state but based on our
experience with New Hampshire's
Brownfield sites and our experience with
landfill permitting we oppose House Bill
1132 we understand that the bill would
require entities that are proposing a
new land F on an undeveloped or Green
Field site to identify Brownfield sites
as alternative locations and demonstrate
whether the Greenfield site or the
Brownfield site would provide greater
public
benefits we have two main concerns with
this proposed
requirement first the characteristics of
New Hampshire's Brownfield sites are not
usually consistent with the
characteristics needed for a landfill
site
most landfills require at least 100
acres and most of New Hampshire's
Brownfield sites are not that big also
our Brownfield sites are typically
former manufacturing facilities Mill
facilities commercial facilities usually
on small parcels and also in town
centers which is not a desirable
location for a
landfill assuming that an applicant
could find a brown field site with an
appropriate size and location for citing
a landfill the bill would require the
applicant to uh determine whether the
Green Field site or the brown field site
had greater public benefit uh but we
would find this provision as the bill is
written right now um unclear and
difficult to
administer the bill doesn't provide
criteria for assessing relative degrees
of public benefit and we're not sure how
we would evaluate the applicant's
comparison also the requirement to
identify alternative brownfields
locations doesn't appear to give
consideration to whether the Brownfield
sites would be available for
acquisition for this reason the bill
could result in applicants devoting
resources to carrying out evaluations
that were really hypothetical exercises
and not uh really meaningful evaluation
of
alternatives for those reasons we oppose
the bill and I would be happy to take
your
questions representa Murray thank you
madam chair um and thank you um for the
opportunity to ask you a question and
maybe a followup if I may sure um the
first question I do have is uh with the
responsibility of some of these Brown
field sites are there those that are
perpetuity I want to be sure that I
understand your question
um is your question whether the current
owner of the site would be
required
um well monitoring would be required
until there was no contamination
remaining at the site so that's should
not be in perpetuity but it could be for
many many years decades
as far as who would be responsible for
that monitoring that would depend on
sales did you have a follow up yeah
thank you followup if I may so I guess
that was that was my question so if if
there is a legal obligation under an
original property held by anybody who
who currently is on that list of brown
sites that you folks all Monitor and it
was potentially purchased from somebody
else would that absolve
the
original in the purchase and sale is
that what you're seeming to indicate or
is that it all depends how how it's
crafted thank you representative NAB
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question and for being here
today um one of your concerns seems to
be about defining the public benefit or
comparing the Public Public benefit but
in the second paragraph of your
testimony you outline the way the public
benefit is assessed for a landfill site
couldn't you use some of that criteria
to develop a comparison between a
Brownfield site and a green field
site in the written testimony it
discusses how public benefits determined
for a
landfill
um our difficulty would be criteria for
assessing for weighing the different
factors of P public benefit for one
property as opposed to for another
property the way that the uh
requirements are written right now now
for public benefit determination it's
focused on one one piece of property so
when you get into the the value
judgments between one property and
another uh there's not currently
that followup thank you is that
something that could be done in rulle
making or within the department or do
you think that's something that needs to
be outlined in the bill if it was to
move
forward for rule making we take our
guidance from the statutes so uh Clarity
in the statute would guide the rul
making representative H Haskins thank
you madam chair and thank you for taking
my question so public benefit it would
seem then is always going to be at some
level of value judgment there are lots
of criteria you can outline them go
through them one to 10 but judgments
right for this bill a judgment would
have to be made between the public
benefit of one site public benefit of
another yeah and public benefit is a
part of the permanent process so anytime
at some level judge those judgments have
to be made do they not I'm not prepared
to comment on uh the public benefit
process for landfill permitting in
specific okay thank you representative
Duty
um thank you madam chair I'm confused
okay uh because uh we have an issue
there was a meeting last night I was not
able to attend but in New Hampshire uh
in Nashua um we have a sighting for an
ashalt plant that is going to be right
downtown okay and in meetings with the
dees uh we were clearly told that at the
next public hearing that no one could
make any comment comments regarding
issues involved with air quality due to
uh diesel trucks um uh you know standing
you know waiting to get into the ashal
plant that the only thing that the
public could comment on were scientific
evidence rate relating to the permitting
okay so and in reading some of the
statements that Dees has made about
environmental impacts and what their
mission statement is uh it seems to me
that
Dees um isn't clear in terms of what it
deems to be the public benefit and when
the public can weigh in on concerns that
it has about contamination or or air
quality so you know can you help me
understand this because you know you say
here um that it again assessing relative
degrees of public benefit but everything
that I've heard from Dees says that they
can only evaluate things on on technical
qualifications in technical statements
made in the permitting and they can't
take in you know environmental factors
that may be of concern so can you
clarify that sure well when you're
talking about the proposed asphalt plan
in naswa you're talking about an
entirely different set of statutes and
rules from what we're talking about here
because that's the air statutes and air
rules and here we're talking about
the solid waste rules and solid waste
statute and um and that's
the uh part of the statutes that this
bill would apply to
so we're to some degree talking apples
and oranges when we're talking about
statements that might have been made
about an air permitting site as opposed
to potentially weighing public benefit
between two properties proposed for a
landfill to be
cited just one
followup okay so you're saying that if
we amend this bill uh to clarify what we
consider to be the public benefit then
Dees would welcome
that I'm saying that one of the concerns
that we have with the bill is that it
does not provide criteria for weighing
relative public benefit between two
properties representative ktoa
thank you madam chair and thank you for
being here um I had asked the uh Prime
sponsor earlier about the acreage and
you had mentioned that most landfills or
at least 100 acres of the landfills in
New
Hampshire what are they are most of them
100 acres or most of them more that
would be my first question that's a
great question brownfields oh I'm sorry
the brownfields well the Brownfield no
no land Fields oh uh landfills we can
get that information for you but uh I
anticipate they would mostly be over 100
acres followup uh thank you for that
information and that would have been my
thought that most landfills are over 100
acres and most of the brown Fields
except for one are only 100 acres is
that am I understanding that correctly
there's an inventory that includes
313 New Hampshire Brownfield sites and I
would say there's a a small handful of
sites that exceed a 100
acres but for other reasons related to
their
characteristics would not be suitable
for a landfill one more followup thank
you madam chairman thank you again um of
some of these Brown Fields would you say
that
um a good number of them are along
waterways many Brownfield sites are
right on top of a Waterway uh if you
look at photos overhead photos aerial
photos of the brownfields project in
conquered that was recently completed uh
to convert the former Allied Tannery
into senior housing you see that that
senior housing is here and the water the
river is right
there okay representative
ger thank you madam chair thank you for
for taking my question
uh we heard before the comparison with
Wetlands right and and so that if if
there is a proposal to build in Wetlands
you'd have to be able to you meet a
number of criteria right in order to
demonstrate that that is a suitable
place to put it and that there isn't a
better place to put it so that would
seem to me to involve comparison that's
a comparison between a given site and
being able to demonstrate that that site
is better or worse than an alternative
site so I'm a little bit confused about
the idea that we don't have the capacity
to make comparisons between a proposed
site and an alternative site so could
you explain to us how this would be
different from how we make these
determinations with regard to
Wetlands I'm a geologist in the waste
management division so I can't speak to
how the determinations are made in the
wetlands rules uh but what what we can
say is that this bill does not provide
the criteria for that sort of
comparison
representative H
Haskins thank you madam chair and thank
you for my question so does it
follow um if a brown field near a
Waterway is problematic that a green
field near a Waterway is problematic as
well there are sighting requirements for
landfills in New Hampshire and there's a
setback required to a Waterway uh these
brownfields projects that we talk about
Brownfield sites that we talk about
which are right on top of the water
would not meet the sighting criteria for
a landfill follow up if I may um yeah
sure you happen to know the acreage of
the Bethlehem
landfill no but that's in the
information that we're going to get to
the
committee represent big thank you yeah
so one of the things that's come up in
previous discussions of fills is whether
the hydrogeology of a site is
appropriate for a landfill in terms of
being in terms of setback from waterways
in terms of the paracity of the ground
uh in terms of uh whether there are uh
aquafer major aquifers uh under or near
the site is that are those
hydrogeological considerations something
that could um
uh limit the number of brown fields that
site well I would say that in the same
way those considerations limit any type
of property that's appropriate for a
landfill uh they would apply to
Brownfield sites as
well thank
you representative Murray you had a
question I did thank you um I the
question that I had for you is that I'm
that brownfields have have as some have
mentioned before been turned into
transfer stations Parks provided
alternate locations for uh residential
housing um those types of things um so
when those types of projects are being
considered
um what is the metric then for those
types of
projects moving forward or not versus
something like obviously we were talking
about acreage is one one facet um are
there
is there a separate set of Standards or
metrics used to consider other things as
opposed to landfill sighting that's a
good question and I think it would
depend on what type of facility or um
business someone is looking to site some
of the types of places that you
mentioned uh like transfer stations do
require a different type of a solid
waste permit uh and other types like
residential facilities would not require
a permit to be
built from not from waste management at
least represent
Penza so the the landfill that's in
Lebanon is uh
15.35 Acres um Lebanon sorry
um why wouldn't we look at the
313 sites and do that kind of evaluation
based upon you know looking at the
current rules and then and then see I
mean in a sense we only need possibly
one one or two landfills in the entire
State of New Hampshire over the next 60
to 100 years so to me it it it just
seems crazy to not look at
it it seems as if you're you're just
blanketly saying that
this is you know this wouldn't work or
this wouldn't work why aren't we why
aren't we looking at it why isn't why
aren't we looking at all of the
opportunities that we have in 313 before
out I've stated de's position on the
bill when an entity is looking to say at
a landfill they look at many different
options for places to site the landfill
and they may be looking at some of these
sites
um but de's position is that we oppose
this bill representative Bixby yes so uh
one this this is kind of a hypothetical
but one of the things that seems to be
coming into play here is that Dees
doesn't actually get to uh make the
choice about where uh landfills are
going to be cited or because it's in the
it's a private entity that is looking to
to uh site the landfill and that private
entity seems to be in control of that
process so the hypothetical part of this
is if it were uh the state rather than
uh a private entity uh that were looking
to S landfills would that open up the
possibility of uh looking at more of the
sites I I don't believe
the
the background of the entity whether
it's a government entity or a private
entity would uh have an impact on would
would
change the implementation of this bill
as it's proposed I don't believe that
that would make a difference thank
you I have a question so given the 313
Brownfield sites that we have
have just a wild
guess how many of those do you think
would be appropriate for any kind of
landfill I mean number one we're looking
at space size the size of one so that
rules out a whole bunch of
them then we would be looking at perhaps
you know being too close to a school or
urban center or waterway that would rule
out another bunch of
them there are some other considerations
obviously you'd have to take into
account and you know when you're looking
at landfills they basically site
specific anyway but just you know any
kind do you have any kind of guess as to
how many of those
313 might be any kind of um candidate
for a landfill as stated in the
commissioner's letter we don't believe
that any of them would be okay thank you
for that representative
ger thank you madam chair and thank you
again for taking my question so I want
to return to the the question about the
lack of clarity from the legislature
regarding criteria right so particularly
public benefit uh
but and how you would compare one site
versus another what that criteria is
wouldn't it be what I'm thinking about
in terms of this bill is isn't that
precisely what this bill does it would
be if it passed
clear instruction by the legislature
that brown Fields should always be
preferred to Green Fields if they meet
our landfill sighting criteria so my
question is if that's the concern that
there isn't
Clarity from the legislature about what
that criteria is I'm a little bit
puzzled about the opposition here
because this bill actually provides
precisely that
criteria as I said by saying the brown
Fields should always be preferred if
they meet condition so wouldn't this
provide the kind of clarity that Dees is
issue the bill States the department
shall require an applicant seeking
permits for a Landfield on a Greenfield
site to identify alternative Brownfield
sites within the state that could
reasonably provide similar public
benefits and demonstrate for all such
Brownfield sites whether the Greenfield
site provides greater public benefits
and if so by how much
it's not clear how we would
determine the degree we how we would
evaluate someone's description of the
degree to which a Greenfield site
provides more public benefit than a
Brownfield site may I follow up Madam
chair thank you so sure I I appreciate
that and and so then would it
conceivably work to have an amendment
that would just effectively State as I
said that uh Brownfield site
are preferable to Greenfield sites right
that's the criteria I hear what you're
saying how do we quantify that this site
is so much better than this site but if
the statement on on the part of the
legislature is that a Brownfield site is
always better than a green field site if
it meets sting criteria uh that doesn't
get us into the realm of how do you
quantify it it is a value statement so
with that type of amendment perhaps
provide more clarity for
Dees that would provide more clarity but
not a all of de's
concerns representive
kraton thank you madam chair thank you
again ladies for taking our
questions you haven't listened to all
this I just want to give you a
hypothetical and tell me if you think it
make if this is sort of the way it goes
down I want to put a landfill site
typically in this state I'm going to
need more than 100 acres so I go to Dees
and say I want to put in a landfill site
you say great there's 30 3 possible
places to
go go and analyze those based on this
bill that's what it tells me to do go
and analyze those so you give them the
thing and they look at it and they say
well of that 313 only a handful are
greater than 100 acres and of that
handful none of them meet the
requirements for setbacks to waterways
towns schools whatever those
requirements are so thank you very much
of the 313 none of them meet the Acres I
require to put my landfill in is that
down yes thank
you representative Penza and then
representative
Murray okay so I'm going to go back to
the
313 because earlier in the testimony you
had stated that you know you weren't
aware of all the crit IIA of what you
know these 313 are but then you said
that they're that zero of them
are um not
appropriate I I don't understand how you
can have that both ways then shouldn't
there be a report I'd love to see a
report of every
313 of all of them and it doesn't have
to be 100 acres can it be
15.75 like I just I don't understand why
we're not looking at
it
I don't recall saying that I wasn't
aware of criteria associated with the
Brownfield sites so I'm not sure how to
question you basically said that you you
weren't aware followup sorry you weren't
aware of all you know all 313 sites you
said for example you know you know that
a few of them or a handful of them are
over a hundred um you don't know every
makeup of every Brownfield site
obviously
so and then you stated that zero of them
that you feel would be appropriate I'm
just I don't understand how you can
qualify that statement when I would love
to see a report then if you guys have a
report on hand of the 313 Brownfield
sites I think that would be fantastic to
send it to the committee so we know um
where these where these all stand I
don't have here with me the details on
every one of the 313 sites I've spoken
with the engineer in charge of our
brownfields program who confirmed with
me that there's not one of those sites
that she's aware of that's appropriate
for citing a landfill for various
reasons associated with their
characteristics Miss Kern do you does
dees have a brownfields report that
talks about all of these different sites
and what their characteristics are I
don't believe that there's a report uh
that would have summaries of all of the
sites okay that information is stored in
individual files would be very time
consuming to compile thank you
representative Murray thank you madam
chair um if the department could tell me
of the
313 Roundfield sites that are also on
the database that I can look through and
sort um how many of them are privately
here but we could get that for you thank
you
okay one other question representative
Duty um thank you madam
chair so uh I I believe that it's still
in in statute unless we've changed it
and I can't remember um that there's a
200 foot setback from a Waterway did we
did that ever pass or is that still
law I'm going to ask Leah to speak to
this I believe it's in the solid waste
rules correct that's an administrative
rule it's not in statute okay but it's
an administrative rule okay so the the
question I have is is I don't understand
uh why if we have the 200 foot setback
um that we have to rule out all
brownfields that are near a Waterway
since we have a Brownfield in nashwa
right on the the old copper plant okay
and it they're mitigating it they've
been mitigating it for the last 5 years
and they put up they engineered a slurry
wall okay to keep the creosol from going
into the miramac river so I mean if that
in fact Works uh couldn't you do a
slurry wall 200 feet in from from a a a
water body um to protect it from lee8
going into the river and if you're have
100 or 110 acres 200 ft from a water
body you know you still have a lot of
land to be able to use for the landfill
just
asking you bring up a topic that there's
a lot of work going into right now at
Dees the appropriate protective setbacks
for landfills from surface water so we
are working on that right now in our
update of the solid waste rules the
solid waste rules do
allow uh permit to get a waiver of the
rules if they can come up with an
alternative to a requirement in the
rules that is as protective as what the
rules
require uh
so if there was a
site that had a need for something like
that that could be considered for a
waiver I don't know whether it could be
demonstrated to be as protective or
not okay any other questions from the
Comm
seeing none I want to thank you very
much for coming and speaking with us
today anybody else from the audience
have a pink
card um with that I'm going to close the
public hearing for HB 1132 I'd like to
see the blue
sheet and uh let's see online
uh we have
this is
[Music]
11:32
oops we had online 19 people in favor
and one person in
opposition of this bill and on the blue
sheet we have five people signed in in
favor
there you go thank
you okay I am now going to open up a
public hearing on hb1 1170 requiring
public benefit and Community impact
assessments from the Department of
Environmental
Services and here to introduce the bill
to us is representative Wendy
Thomas welcome to environment
agriculture thank you
um and committee members does everybody
have a copy of the
bill okay thank you and what I'm also
passing around are two amendments um to
this bill and I'll explain um why
they're both needed uh for the record I
am representative Wendy Thomas I
represent the town of marac Hillsboro uh
District
12 the reason for this bill um is
because uh the the town of MCH in
particular was very concerned oh and
actually I'm going to be joined up here
by representative germana who's whose
name is on um the the two amendments as
well okay and I I remind representative
ger that if you are testifying you won't
questions um do you have copies of the
Amendments oh they're coming they're
going around thank you so um the reason
for this bill is is there was a lot of
concerned about um an air permit that
was being uh considered for uh s Caine
in marac now this is a company that has
lied over and over and over about what
they do and how much um emissions they
have put forward um they lied about a
bypass that they had to use um and in
several meetings with Dees prior to um s
Cain saying they were going to close but
prior to the the um this uh permit we
were told that Dees is a regulatory
committee and or a regulatory agency and
they do not even though it's in their
mission statement they do not need to
consider people or the environment they
don't need to protect it they um they we
were at a meeting and we were
specifically told that if a corporation
checks off all of the boxes that are
necessary for a permit they're given
that permit regardless of whether or not
there's going to be an impact to the
community
uh as you can probably imagine uh with
the history that we have in miramac that
just won't float and so initially when
we when we came up with the idea for
this bill we had sort of an idea that
just
all-encompassing Dees would have to
consider public benefit and Community
impact well you can't really do that you
can't go into any agency and make a
massive change like that and um we
understood but that was sort of the mud
that we put up on the wheel and so in
discussion with Dees in discussion with
some uh industry experts we decided that
instead of making a massive change which
I actually argue would be for the better
but I understand that logistically it's
not the best thing we were just going to
take one permit the land fill permit
just one and put wording into the the
process for this where um they would
have they Dees would have to consider uh
environmental impact or they consider
public benefit and environment and
Community impact I'm sorry so on
Amendment which is uh
09h on lines 10 through 12 it identifies
exactly what we're talking about and
what Dees should consider for a landfill
permit which includes human health
property values tourism outdoor
recreation and
Wildlife um to cons or to figure out the
impacts of these they should also they
should be looking at noise odor traffic
groundwater pollution and surface water
pollution greenhouse gas and other
emissions so this is this amendment uh
to this bill would simply consider one
permit and then if we pass this and we
see in a year that that the agency has
not blown up and in fact they have done
a good job protecting the communities
with these permits then perhaps we could
extend it to other permits so that's um
that's
the uh Amendment for for uh public input
there's another amendment do you want to
do you want to bring this one forward
sure and if I may also speak uh about
some of the other
reasons why the uh 190 uh the amendment
that we're proposing 190 is needed to to
address some specific issues one has to
do with providing support for local
communities because as it stands right
now there's a public input session and
local communities have the opportunity
to present their concerns uh but public
communities you know our our local
communities don't necessarily have the
resources they need to hire experts to
hire lawyers to hire geologists to do
the types of uh investigations that
permit applicants can do I mean they're
inherently at a disadvantage so this
bill would require the applicant who
wants to place a facility in a community
to uh through a third party
do this work uh on behalf of the
community that they want to site that
they want to have a facility and so it's
addressing a specific needs of
communities to have the resources they
need to be able to um to help evaluate
the the the
applications we also specifically
expanded here it refers to in line seven
to the host community and ab budding
municipalities it's important for us
right to recognize we all do that uh it
doesn't you know these types of
facilities aren't they're located in one
town but they affect of towns all around
that area right you've got trucks coming
in and out you have the potential for
air pollutants water pollutants uh Etc
right so any type of evaluation of the
impact has to be Regional and has to
affect a variety of um communities that
are AB budding the community where the
facility is the other part of this bill
um which is down in lines 20 to
23 uh also makes it clear that when
we're talking about public benefit as
well as harm uh that it has to be
specific to the facility that is being
proposed you cannot use a second
facility somewhere else in order to
argue that you're enhancing the public
benefit or diminishing the public harm
it has to be specific to the facility
that you are applying for um and just
one more addition to this this um
amendment is uh the F the original
fiscal note was pretty awful um if you
if you read it um it by having the
corporations pay for this study it
eliminates that fiscal note and I I'm
sure you're going to have to have a
person to oversee it but this is again
one
permit uh thank you and and so in
reference to the Second Amendment and by
the way we off we decided to offer
represent Thomas and I two separate
amendments because we we think that they
deal with kind of two different things
uh and we don't want them necessarily to
have to be tied to one another so that
we can kind of discuss them take leave
whatever amend as as needed but we felt
it was better off for the committee's
purposes to have these as two separate
amendments rather than one Amendment but
the Second Amendment
d187 was draft it in response to the
December Supreme Court uh decision
regarding public benefit um I have a
copy of it it's online but I'm also
happy to to to provide it for the
committee uh this was a dispute
involving conservation law Foundation uh
and uh uh
ncees and uh and Dees as well and there
was a debate over how to
determine public benefits specifically
with regard to capacity and need right
and so one side was arguing I believe
the conservation law Foundation was
arguing that you need to be able to
demonstrate need for that facility for
effectively every day of the lifetime of
that
facility the more you know on the other
end is the argument that you only need
to demonstrate effectively one day of
need right if there's any shortfall at
all even for one day of the lifetime of
that permit that that constitutes need
the court determined that Dees has
considerable statutory flexibility to
determine what need means right uh and
so
this uh amendment that we're offering
here is a
solomonic uh solution to the problem uh
which is to say that when we look at the
lifetime of the permit you need to be
able to demonstrate need for at least
half of the lifetime of that permit uh
and that splits the difference between
the two positions that were argued
before the court uh so in this case what
through this amendment we're asking the
legislature to do is to provide specific
direction to Dees uh and to say that
when considering need uh need has to be
demonstrated as you said for at least
one half of the lifetime of the permit
for the uh specific
facility and the amendment also uh
stipulates that a new facility would not
be able to operate until the year of the
shortfall so for example if they're
holding if they're if they've applied
for a 10-year permit and there's a an
anticipated shortfall in in year nine
they wouldn't be able to start operating
until year nine they wouldn't be able to
open up a landfill and use it and you
know for the first nine years just
because there was that anticipated
shortfall in year nine so this this
amendment also addresses that
representative Thomas wouldn't that
create a monopoly where you would only
have
you know
one this new one Land one new landfill
what if what if there were two new
landfills coming
online
um then then you're not you're how do
you assess that shortfall there is no
shortfall
really we currently have two large
landfills in New Hampshire right right
so and theoretically they're both being
active because there's a shortfall this
would be for for any new landfill not
existing landfill right so but then
you're saying that there would only be
one new landfill at a time that would be
coming
online and not any others new
ones I mean what if what if we wanted
you know to place two new landfills
somewhere wow I mean just just
hypothetically not that you know we
would go crazy putting landfills all
over but yeah I hope we don't no but I'm
just saying it it just seems like this
kind of creates a monopoly of of a one
new landfill coming online well if if I
may speak to that Madam chair uh I I
think that if we're talking about given
our current
capacity if we were looking at two new
landfill permits there is no way two new
landfills are required to meet our needs
right so right there it creates a
problem because uh this is simply not uh
they would not be permittable I mean
there's no reason to to even think about
permitting two new landfills because we
don't even begin to have the need for
two new landfills so I think it would it
would have to be in the sense of like
who got their permit application in
first and that that is
uh I I think a perfectly reasonable
process you know we there's only so much
need you have people apply to provide a
service for that need and you would do a
first come first serve basis in terms of
eval Val ating permit applications and
Madam chair it would only be a monopoly
if the same company is chosen
consistently
correct possibly um Switching gears I
also have a question with regard to the
09h um lines 9 through 14 the assessment
shall include harms that a landfill
would likely cause
by identifying and determining any
potentially harmful impacts on human
health property values tourism outdoor
recreation and
wildli such impacts may include noise
odor odor uh traffic groundwater
pollution surface water pollution
greenhouse gas and other emissions
emanating from the facility and to
include the emissions from transport of
solid waste related material and
byproducts to and from the proposed
facility how do you envision all of that
being
Quantified that's a good question
um I'm not sure of the metrics but there
there have to be
metrics that that for example I mean I
get for noise you can measure decb right
um so transportation we were talking
about Road usage so if if the roads that
are being used with these heavy heavy
trucks um have to be repaired more more
often than not I mean that's a statistic
you could use human health you would
um well so this would be for a new
landfill I mean the biggest one is any
any pasas I mean any environmental
toxins the potential for human health if
they escape would be something to be
considered that would still be
um you know something they'd have to
guess at they don't have any hard fast
you know
numbers right and if I may thank you
madam chair uh there's nothing in the
bill that states that the assessment of
impact has to be Quantified certainly
some of them would require Quant you
know quantity if you're talking about
home values uh certainly if you're
talking about noise as you pointed out
these are things that can be Quantified
but considering for example tourism
right uh the assessment would take a
look at what are some of the major
tourist draws in the area and say that
building a landfill next to a site that
is a heavily um you know visited site
you don't need to quantify that I mean
these are things I would argue to the
committee that we would all want if this
facility a facility like this was being
built in our communities these are
precisely the things that we would want
to know how is it going to impact local
tourism in our our area how is it going
to impact uh property values how is it
going to to uh impact wildlife and some
of these as I said are are quantifiable
but some of them are kind of uh
qualifiable in the sense that they are
statements about the fact that you're
building facility in close proximity
to uh a natural beauty site like Mount
manad knock down in in the in the
chesher region right so I I hear what
you're saying and and certainly some of
these things can be Quantified like
property values and there's a way to do
that by looking at current landfills and
their potential impact on on property
value and projecting that onto a new
site but as he said some of these are
more quality issues that we all care
about in our communities even if they're
not strictly quantifiable and do you
know whether or not Dees takes these
particular things and quantifies them
when they're currently doing their
permitting I mean now Dees is going to
be coming up in testifying as well and
I'll ask them the same question but I
don't know if you do if you knew that I
look forward to their answer
um the reason for this this bill and the
fir one of the reasons is is that
they're not obligated by law to consider
the impact of permits on public benefit
and Community impact I mean they they it
is in their mission statement but it's
not in law and so so it's you know they
they they do one thing for one permit
one thing for another permit this you
know so there's no consistency about
protecting the people you know or and
and the environment from from some of
these uh the
permits I don't know if that answers
your question and if I could just follow
that up and I realize I want to get to
to the questions that we spent we had
several meetings with director whims and
you know that's not to say that that his
this has a stamp of approval but we
narrowed this down specifically in
response to a number of the questions
and concerns that the director had the
the bottom line here I think is that we
need to be talking about net impact the
problem with our public
benefit the the way we weigh public
benefit is that it doesn't involve a
list of here are the advantages and here
are the disadvantages and now we're
going to compare the two to see which
one comes out on top we don't do that
the only seems to me rational way to
determine whether to go forward is to
have a statement of potential harm and a
statement of potential benefit and to
compare the two otherwise I think we're
stuck with what we hear again and again
and again is that Dees has a hard time
determining what public benefit how it's
defined so and let me ask you with this
uh Amendment uh
09h or and both maybe 0187
H did I hear correctly that director
whimet um had some input into this oh
absolutely okay we had several meetings
with him thank
you representative NAB thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my question
um representative gerana you sort of
just got at a question I have um
regarding the comparison of the benefits
to the negatives but I look at your list
and it's hard for me to think you know
landfills are necessarily evils we need
them but what is a case in which they
would ever increase property values
increase tourism increase Recreation
it's always going to be I would think
this list is always sort of going to
come out negatively the impact of having
a landfill in your area so do you look
at it as a comparison to the benefit of
having the landfill do you look at it as
this spot that's right next to a lake or
right next to a town is worse than if
the spot was a little more remote I mean
how do you think about this list because
I look at it and say your report's never
going to say hey this is great it's
going to be great for all these things
right to have a landfill that's it's
hard to imagine that would ever be the
outcome thank you very much
representative for the question I I
think that you're right it's not going
to come out negative but it should come
out neutral you know I mean we all want
to know know if if citing one of these
things in our community is going to
negatively impact our property values so
the purpose is not to uh have this come
out as a as a say positive impact on the
community but as I said I think we
should all be given um a sense of if
there might be a negative impact and
another thing is and I'm we're playing
tag here and I hope it's not confusing
but um this assessment would allow the
community to have their eyes open so if
it says you know there's potential for
leachate leak into the lake you know
people could maybe start filtering water
now before it becomes an issue or
something like that so it's it's eyes
open for the community I'm not
necessarily saying that you know it's
going to stop any landfills that's not
the point of this the point is if we're
going to have a landfill let's make sure
it's safe let's make sure people know
about any potential hazards and and
let's make sure the benefit out the the
negative part of it representative H
Haskins thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question um
representative gerana I'd like to take
the metaphor of Solomon because I
studied the Hebrew Bible and in that
example the objective was the baby had
to survive when two women said it was
their baby Solomon had to make a
decision if we have risk benefit
analysis that the feds have been doing
for years can't we use some of those
examples to tell us how to do public
benefit how to weigh public
benefit thank you for the question and
and and appreciate your expertise your
theological expertise yes I I agree this
is not Reinventing the wheel this is not
something that people don't already do
right so uh there are processes for this
at the federal level as you point out
and they are certainly adaptable and
applicable uh in New Hampshire thank you
thank you representative
Penza just to kind of follow up on that
because it seemed as if there was a
question that these aren't you know this
would just be you know a guess these are
these are people that have dedicated
their whole lives to risk analysis
public benefit all of that and I mean
all I know is that this happens all the
time for even in private businesses you
know you have to weigh the good versus
the bad to say if it's if it makes sense
for to go forward this isn't just about
landfills this is about everything
correct that falls in the agency
eventually we hope it's about everything
yes representative
Duty uh thank you madam chair um I'll go
back to the comment I made about the
ashalt plant
um the the people of Nashville who came
to that meeting uh hit the floor when
they found out that their concerns about
air quality uh regarding their children
they they lived in those areas uh
children walked to school in that area
and um the ashalt plant was going to be
open I think from 6:00 in the morning
until 5:00 at night and I think they
wanted to operate at least six days a
week maybe 7 days a week and residents
in the community were told that they any
concerns they had about a diminishment
of their quality life could not and
would not be
considered okay and um I just find that
um that that's unconscionable that's
unconscionable especially when
representative Duty do you have a
question yeah the well it's not a
question I'm sorry the statement is I
think that some something like this may
make Industries or people that want to
locate this think about how they can
build these representative duty if you
don't have a question please refrain
okay thank you madam chair yeah
representative sofikitis
um I just um for the record I just want
to know because I had heard that St
gobain was closing are they
closing they um have plans to close this
summer
we're in the process of trying to figure
out what that means as far as cleaning
up the building getting rid of what's
inside the building and cleaning up the
land around it although you can't clean
are there any other questions for
representative
kraton thank you ma'am and thank you for
this bill it
clearly the community impact should be
considered what I'm looking at though is
the is the amendment and I don't
understand how it works what what I
think you're saying is that if I'm going
to put several billions of dollars into
building a landfill that I have to bet
that my timing is correct in terms of
the other
plant closing and my plant opening
otherwise I build this multi-million
dollar plant and I can't open it because
our law now says that you can only have
one based on a
capacity I think that's what you said
you said said you can't open this plant
until the other plant
expires based on the need no no no no no
no that's I don't I I may have misspoken
um you cannot so if if the need is
projected so we we currently have two
plants uh two landfills two large
landfills in New Hampshire um if to put
in a third one um you would have to go
through the the permitting process which
this doesn't change the permitting
process it it changes one one tiny
aspect but you still have to go through
that process um and the only way you
that you should be getting the permit is
if a need and a shortfall is
identified like you know in in five
years we're going to need you know more
landfill capacity so so the the permit
would be given to you on the on the
understanding that in five years that's
what that's when we'll be needing you so
you can build it and everything but this
this second Amendment would say until
that need is here you can't start using
it you can't start using it but it's if
like you said it's a fiveyear lead time
so you I'm it just just seems
exorbitantly complicated to me okay
thank you I'm sorry man I I'll just
speak to that so first of all this this
I would like hopefully Pro s away from
the notion that it can only be one
there's nothing in the bill that that
that that mandates that what it says is
that and this is already part of of
rules that that the question about
public benefit is inseparably linked to
need capacity and need and what we're
saying is that a either an expansion or
a new landfill should not be opened and
begin operating until the point where
there is need this is not uh certainly
it's it's it's a business and necessary
evil as as representative NAB pointed
out but uh we shouldn't be in a
situation and and I know none of us are
are here and thinking that because
companies can make a profit opening
landfills they should just be open be
able to open landfills because they can
make money doing it what we're saying is
that you shouldn't be able to begin
operating an expansion or a new landfill
until the point where there is a
demonstrated need for that landfill so
we're not opening landfills that are
simply not
needed representative Duty thank thank
you madam chair are you aware that I
believe that um these um that this
already exists in the health care field
and in hospitals uh I I believe that
it's my understanding that they have to
go before regulatory board and
demonstrate need before you can build a
new hospital did you check to see if
that's a mo is that the kind of model
that you're using for
this
um the details of this I I spent many
hours this summer talking to uh
legislators from New York State um and
they have um and again it was um past Le
they've got HK Falls which is comparable
to our marac um which is comparable to
Bennington
Vermont um and one of the differences
they have a Department of Environmental
Protection and that's I think that's
what this is trying to do um because
right now we have a department of
Environmental Services which is a
regulatory committee uh again agency not
committee um and so this tries to bring
it in line with more of a
protection for the citizens of New
Hampshire uh
agency and and if I may respond
representative duty to your question and
also try to provide some more clarity I
should have thought about this when I
was responding to representative kraton
I would refer my colleagues to and I can
again submit it uh to the clerk to the
Supreme Court court case Pages 9 through
11 what we are addressing is
specifically in response to the ruling
by the Supreme Court right so when when
I talk about the need to demonstrate
need as it were this is specifically
addressing the issues that were raised
in this ruling and the ruling was that
Dees has considerable regulatory
flexibility in determining what need
means what we are saying is that we as a
legislature have the responsibility of
actually determining what need means and
we we've heard from Dees a number of
times uh that it's difficult for them to
do things without clarification so I'll
submit this and I would ask my committee
colleagues to read the case especially
Pages 9 through 11 because what this
amendment does specifically responds to
the case uh the ruling by the Supreme
Court representative Penza
okay so I was a little confused because
the initial bill does not speak about
landfills and so the the two amendments
replace 100% okay so that's where I
um so would you want both of these to be
applied is really where it would be one
or the other like I'm getting I ideally
we would like both um
however um the uh 90
190 um is more specific about the public
benefit and 87
1887 um addresses that uh Supreme Court
ruling which is included in the
definition of public benefit so ideally
both of them should be should be passed
we just made them separate because we
didn't want one to bog down the
other
representative
Murray thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question to the the
two uh just two of maybe many of the
sponsors sorry um my question is uh are
there other instances in where host
communities are notified in public
comment uh is taken when there are other
um entities or buildings like maybe
jails or nuclear power plants or
anything of the like that are like built
or established in a community is there
any other precedent that um is available
for us to look at aside from rul making
and all of those other things where we
know public is invited to comment but
with specificity to the creation of a
new entity like a new
landfill I I believe um the process that
Dees uses U almost always includes
public input um Community input um
however we were
um I we were were we were told by an
employee of Dees that that they don't
especially for written testimony they
don't look at things like like s Cain
has lied s Cain has has been mistr
truthful s Cain has done this um they
like comments that say there's a typo on
line seven or something like that you
know so again they've reinforced they
are a regulatory agency and even though
they they invite public input um it's
questionable about whether or not they
actually consider uh the actual input to
the community the direct
input yes and I would say I I don't know
the answer and I'll I'll make some
inquiries prisons sound like a an
example of that you know what what we're
saying is that the current process
already
requires permit applicants to make a
case about this is the public benefit
what we are saying is that they should
have to also say here are the and the
word here is potential it's always
potential public benefit they should
also have to speak to potential public
harms that doesn't mean they have to
have a crystal ball the word is
potential uh and so when you're trying
to to put one of these facilities in the
community you should have to present
potential benefits and potential harms
to help Dees make their
decisions any other
questions just represent
Penza just had a question because I was
at said meeting that you were at
and um I brought up the specific um
permit that was in a sense going to be
rubber stamped from s go
Bay and that answer was accurate of we
don't look at correct I mean I just want
to make sure that that is specific that
what we're talking about because I heard
the same exact thing that is what I
heard
any other questions thank you for your
introducing the bill and I would Now
here
thank you Madame chairman good afternoon
for the record my name's Gary Abbott I'm
the Executive Vice President of the
associated general contractors of New
Hampshire I'm here today uh I came
initially opposed to Hill 1170 because
of its far-reaching it basically said
any permit that goes through Dees would
need this extensive study and I was
looking at we get all kinds of permits
air wet lands all kinds of permits
through the department of environmental
service this would delay so many
projects that would uh be affected since
the amendments were proposed I thought
yay I'm good I don't really have to
worry about it landfills is not
necessarily uh something that I would
have to worry about but I want to bring
to your attention because this moner
said maybe everything should be covered
and so I just want to bring up even if
we were to do this assessment and I'm
looking at the original bill I have not
seen the amendment so I can't talk on
landfills but I look at such broad
language as human value safety uh
concerns you know about proper planning
and it's so vague that I don't even know
what a report would look like and I can
tell you this um Dees whenever we go for
a permit you cannot pollute the
environment or you cannot you have to
meet their conditions they're very very
strict they are for protecting the
environment and not only do we have to
go through Dees sometimes fishing game
for alteration of terrain permits it's
not an easy process from an applicant's
aspect to get approval especially if
you're not uh making sure you protect
the environment so I want to put that
the whole question of need this has come
up before but who decides what is need
if I want to build a new building on
conquered down Main Street who decides
that it's needed and what public benefit
so those are the reasons I came against
the initial bill but I think it's
helpful in your discussion on landfill
because there there's definitely
landfills have a different priority it
is for the benefit of the state you know
landfills are going to help all the
communities it's not something many
people go after as far as permits but
those that do have got to meet all the
conditions and go through a very lengthy
process so I don't even know how an
assessment impact would work work and I
think you've had some uh committee
members ask that question
because you could just be getting a
report which costs money that still part
of this makes me think you need to look
at the de's rules for uh landfills and
how they assess because I do think they
look at Road impacts and a whole bunch
of other things already when somebody
goes through the process I'm going on
and on the bulk of me 95% is good that
if you're removing the original Bill 5%
is just a warning that this needs a lot
of clarification in order to understand
what the impact would really do does it
give who decides whether need is a big
need is a is one that's very subjective
what I think is a need might be
different than somebody else has a need
so I I really caution you to look at
that term it's probably a lawyer great
word that they'd love in court and so uh
who would would make that
determination with that I would end my
testimony and since the amendment most
of my opposition would go away with the
killing of the original
Bill thank you any questions from the
committee thank you seeing none thank
deers
so I was very um for the record my name
is Ted deers I'm the uh assistant uh
director of The Water Division at Dees
and it was very fortuitous that I happen
to be sitting next
to Sarah uas Kern assistant director of
the waste management division at Dees so
thank you very much for the opportunity
uh obviously similar to what Mr Abbott
just suggested uh there's 15 people
who've seen this uh these amendments um
and neither of us are one of them so uh
we are ill prepared to comment upon them
you had our comments from the original
bill it sounds like uh you're moving off
of that in some manner um but it sounds
like it's turning over to sort of
landfills so I will turn it over to my
colleague from the waste division thank
you uh we were unaware of these
amendments to this bill but I look
forward to obtaining copies to take to
director whimet so that he can become
familiar with them and then we would be
happy to provide comments on it okay are
there any extra copies at the end of the
table
you okay just receive copies thank you
sure yeah yeah and I I don't expect you
to comment on them um because you
haven't seen it till two seconds ago um
but with regard to any of the other
testimony that you've heard or questions
that you've heard asked um do you have
any any comment on that I don't have any
comment today I believe there's a work
session on this bill tomorrow and we are
not going to be ready to comment on this
or participate in a work session
tomorrow but we would be happy to
we can have a little more time with the
language certainly thank you any
questions representative Marie um yes
thank you I I guess I'm going to ask you
the same question that I asked the prime
sponsor and the co-sponsor and maybe
it's just for you um just regarding
other instances and where uh host
committees are notified public um in
your testimony you do mention that it um
the bill the underlying bill um prior to
its Amendment would require the
Department to engage with each community
in the state to identify benefits and
potential impacts further goes on to
state that it would create a new
requirement for public input both in
community
um the community in which the permit or
project is located as well as
neighboring communities So to that end I
guess I am looking for some clarity as
to whether or not that process already
exists somewhere um aside from like a
rul making hearing or some other type of
circumstance so if you could speak to
that sure I'm going to see if Ted has
some comments on that sure
so again this is back to the original
bill which would have covered um from
our perspective life the universe and
everything so that um in that case we
have lots and lots and lots of different
permits we have something like I can't
remember what the number is 88 um 133
chapters uh of law within the department
and uh you know hundreds of different
kinds of permits that cover lots and
lots of things that have time frames
that extend from years to weeks so
there's a whole spectrum of opportunity
for both public comment and integration
within Community interests as well as
interactions with other state laws and
St State jurisdictions as well as
federal laws and federal jurisdictions
this is pretty complex when you start
getting into that magnitude now if
you're shrooming it down to one thing
then you have an opportunity to be able
to Think Through what does that mean
relative to the existing statutes
Federal
overlays all what the communities
already do how that interacts with local
zoning how that interacts with other
kinds of aspects those are all things
that you can consider program by program
but RIT large it's a pretty big universe
um of things that you're talking about
and a broad spectrum of how those kinds
of interactions happen does that get at
follow follow up yeah thank you if I may
so if what I'm hearing is um that the
scope were narrowed perhaps that it
would be of more use to allow a
framework in which it is clearly defined
for public comment um to neighboring or
host communities is that what you're
saying versus a broad I guess I would
just say that it would totally depend on
which statute and which permit you're
talking about and how you would like to
conversation any other questions from
the committee seeing none thank you very
much for stepping up and speaking with
us are there any other pink uh folks in
the audience who'd like to um make
comment on this bill seeing none I'd
like the blue
sheet and let's see here on
HB 1170 I have 10 online 10 uh people in
sheet we
have seven in support of HB
1170 with that I'm going to close out
the hearing on HB
1170 and look it we've only gone over
one
minute I'll open up a hearing for hb1
1620 relative to suspending the issuance
of new landfill permits until
have our work session is later the after
after we're
done um no wait a minute where am I it's
tomorrow sor
no no no our work session will be uh
afternoon so um what I have for hb1
1620 uh introducing the bill is sponsor
representative Ros for welcome to
environment agriculture yes thank you
madam chair thank you members of the
committee I uh appreciate the time that
you gave me I do want to say my new
colleague representative sha Durkin
wishes he was here but he couldn't make
it so he sends his best regards um
before you today is HB
1620 and it's a pretty straightforward
bill I hope that's probably uh worst
thing I could probably say but um
ultimately the the the the packet I just
handed you um I'm going to actually be
using this today and tomorrow I'll be
back again tomorrow for another bill and
um this is the first few pages of the
committee report the final committee
report for the committee to study
unlimited service area permits for
landfills and out of state waste coming
into New Hampshire so I've got this bill
today I've got another bill coming
tomorrow so I will be referring to this
uh um on both days for as you probably
recall that was a bill that uh uh or a
study committee that met um over the
summer I know Madam chair came to at
least one of our meetings and we ended
up with a number of findings and uh
that's on
page on the third page in the
recommendations and this bill today
actually speaks to one of those
recommendations and that is the
consideration of a moratorium against
the construction of new landfills and uh
we felt in the committee that uh the con
concept should at least be discussed and
presented to to you folks to um to
consider and I want to actually talk
about the word moratorium sometimes
people get worried about that concerned
about it uh I don't think there's any
intention here amongst myself and
amongst others um to eliminate landfills
entirely I think that uh uh
representative the previous hearing said
you know it's it's a necessary evil that
we have to deal with um the fortunate
thing that we have in New Hampshire is
we have plenty of capacity of landfills
in fact looking at uh the B annual Solid
Waste report from Dees we have capacity
until 20 33 34 is um even in 20 2030 we
have an excess of 363,000 tons so we
don't have a gun to our head we have we
have the luxury of time to talk about
this and and and consider this and
that's one of the things things the
findings of the committee said there are
a lot of moving Parts with this um and
so how do we deal with solid waste and
landfills and capacity and one of the
things that we considered was in the in
the committee is recycling Advanced
recycling incineration um uh having
having more utilization of recycled
products and really what this bill does
is it buys us
Time by stopping the issuance of uh
landfill permits to consider those
things to consider those other options
as we move forward um I mean there were
topics that we discussed I know the
chair was there that really you know I
think that you know bipartisan B bamal
uh uh committee really said you know we
really should be spend spending some
time on this and U there may be some
legitimate real answers to this problem
that's been uh that's been going on for
quite some time so um
the point being is this this pauses the
issuance of of new uh landfill permits
but it doesn't stop the department from
accepting and investigating applications
so that's the other thing too if you
look at line five of the bill the
department shall continue to accept and
investigate applications so it gives the
opportunity for things to come in um the
the uh the department to to investigate
these and um and and really ruminate on
on on them and study them um and then
they and it holds off the issuance to
2031 and the other opt as you as you
this committee knows we are having new
rules in development uh that should be
out in July maybe I think I've heard um
I've seen a draft of those I'm sure I
know you have been briefed on that as
well so this also not only does it give
pause while those new rules are be being
considered but if the same staff that
are developing the rules are also
reviewing the permits it gives uh gives
um the other topic that we discussed is
um which I'll be talking about tomorrow
I'm going to save that for tomorrow and
again really is you know a pause on the
issuance of of permits we find that this
is probably the most El personally I
think this is the most El solution to
this issue with so many moving parts and
um and it just gives us time because we
do have the capacity we have plenty of
capacity here in the state of New
Hampshire one of the things that I
wanted to talk about really quickly and
I was going to have a an economist here
but he's hung up in oh he's he's here I
will wait on that then um is the fiscal
note so he he he arrived right on right
on right on Q um and with that I'm going
to hand it over to the committee and uh
I'm available for
questions represent viby okay so I think
that you're aware that there is
currently another permit that has been
submitted for uh the landfill uh attempt
in Dalton and I was wondering uh how
this bill would affect that and whether
the fact that the uh bill is going to be
processed after the uh that permit has
was submitted
uh has an impact on how this bill would
work yeah so that's a good question it's
a relevant question and this bill was
actually submitted prior to that
application being being uh sent in so um
I don't know if this was you know we
knew that this was coming this
application up north I don't know if
this was the bill that expedited that
submission or not I've been told that it
probably was but um uh that is is that
is a good question and something that
forward representative H Haskins thank
you madam chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
I'm interested in um lines five and six
the department shall continue to accept
and investigate applications what what
did you have in mind with that so the
the point is is they will again
building off the last question we had
anticipated a a an application being
filed uh I did not anticipate it being
filed when it was so but the the intent
was is that people can you know
applicants can submit an application
they can send in an application for a
landfill um the dees can work on the
application but it won't issue the final
permit until
2031 followup M CH followup thank you um
one of one of my concerns all along has
been that the rul making process is
going on at the same time that the
permit is being reviewed and it seems to
me that Dees has indicated to us that
they are somewhat under staffed and
underfunded and I wonder whether it
makes sense to you that an application
be reviewed when the rul making is going
on and and and again being that there's
no pressure with this I mean it's 2031
is where where we have the uh the time
frame so there's no immediate need to to
process I mean they can uh process or uh
investigate an application but they
don't have to this kind of this will put
the pause on that so if they want to
allocate staff to develop rules and put
this aside while they do that they they
can one of the other things that I think
you you bring up a good point is that
you know we have rules that are
developing and we have we have
we have conditions that are evolving
right now in the state I mean we have a
a a landfill right now that's leaking p
and it's headed towards a river and you
know I mean I know that there is Dees
contends that it's not actively leaking
it was from prior to the landfill when
it was when it was uh unlined but we
have other groups that you know would
would disagree with that so I mean those
are major issues I mean that's that's
something that should be settled it
should be figured out before we move
forward with any new landfills I mean
having gone through this now for a
second year myself personally here but
watching this issue since I was in eth
grade I I grow grew up in the north
country and when it was sandco we've all
been watching this whole thing develop
um you know we've always wondered what's
going to happen when that's when it hits
the water and just a year ago we were
here and Dees was saying uh well these
are double lined and triple lined and uh
um you know we're not going to worry
about it it's safe but my colleague once
said you know if the Titanic was wrapped
in bubble wrap would you still go on it
I mean that's so the question the point
being is there are some real questions
that have to be answered and you know
anyone I know there are folks that are
followed the past stuff going down in
marac U we have the Air Force Base U we
just in my Committee in ways and means
we talked about a leak that you know it
was cleaned up years ago but the the on
the land but now it's leaking into Squam
Lake um so the point being is that uh I
mean the yeah the rules are being
developed but and and and Dees can work
on the permits while this pause is
taking place but the reality is I think
we got to get the rules right we have to
get the permitting right before we
before we do anything because I mean I I
I say this personally I I literally I my
my earth science teacher in seven eth
and nth grade was talking to us about
the sanco landfill which is now in Beth
NC he said once those go in you will
never get them out and it's true once
the stuff is in the ground good or bad
we're stuck with it forever so we've got
to get this right and uh this adds us
time it pumps the brakes it gives us a
little space gives us a little margin so
we can do the best thing indeed thank
you represent ger thank you madam chair
thank you for representative for taking
my question I'm going to ask you to
address one of the critiques of the bill
uh that commissioner Scott included in
the letter that he sent to the committee
and you were copied on that on that
letter uh but to revisit for a moment
the time we spent together in that study
committee one of the things we talked
about right was uh what it means to be
vested when when we talk to Dees and to
the Attorney General's office thinking
about what we could do and what we could
wouldn't do what it means for a company
to be vested right um and the reason why
I bring that up is because in the letter
uh commissioner Scott uh on the one hand
expressed his concern that this doesn't
address potential capacity needs and the
next paragraph he acknowledges but then
criticizes the bill for actually
addressing potential capacity needs by
saying that would be unfair to Grant
extensions of current landfill
right rather than provide a new uh
provide a permit for a new landfill
potentially so could could you speak to
that that criticism and specifically to
how current landfills are already vested
right so the that the granting of an
expansion is not the same as the
granting of a new landfill because
existing landfills are already vested
and potential landfills are not yes
thank you representative um for the
record I I have not read my email I've
been in committee all morning so I have
not read that I know that you said you
you you you said I've got it so I'm sure
it's sitting there uh um uh in my in my
email box but I can talk about you know
the difference between when when we
created the bill uh we felt it was
important that landfills that are
already operating should be allowed to
expand under under their current
guidelines um this goes out to going
into new landfills and I think the talk
earlier today about Green Space versus
brown space really comes into play here
uh a landfill that's already been
permitted it's already been accepting
garbage it's there the garbage is there
it's it's it's it's you know the the
horse is out of the the barn there if
you will um you know any you
know we're assuming that monitoring is
being done the wells are being monitored
uh the structure is in place to to do
that to the best of our ability as of
today going into a new facility I mean
the one that comes to mind is Dalton you
know it's a it's a green space there's
never been trash there um it's it's
sitting next to a lake but as soon as
you start putting stuff in there like I
said it's there it's going to be there
forever so I think the the the the point
being is that you know we protect our
pristine areas for now until we get it
right but we allow those that are
continuing to do business with breast
practices I've been to these facilities
and it's I you know if you haven't been
to a landfill in New Hampshire I would
encourage you to do so because you know
the stuff that goes on there is really
quite remarkable um you know but they're
doing things to the best best practices
who's to say best practices five years
are going to be from now are going to be
best
practices today when I was in eth grade
best practices were to throw it in a big
pit and you know today we would line
that pit we'd say because you know that
pit may or may not be leaking it's
leaking sometime it started leaking
sometime whether or not it was back then
or now I don't know but um you know
there's differences of opinion that so I
hope that addressed your
question may
followup yeah sure thank you reedly but
thank you uh and could you also just
very briefly uh sens of time and I know
you also have to leave to get to your
daughter's play today so don't want to
take too much more time but um could you
also speak to one of the other things
that we discussed in the committee which
is you're talking about what we might be
doing five years from now we've had a
lot of discussion in this committee
about Advanced recycling for example so
if isn't it the case that the capacity
issues we will be addressing them by
pursuing plans that we have regarding
food waste diversion and advanced
recycling that will also ease some of
the capacity uh issues
correct yeah that that that will and and
I'm one of the things that was mentioned
in the fiscal and I'm not going to speak
to the fiscal note per se we've got
someone here that uh is uh is much
better at that than I am but one of the
things they talked about is that it's
going to increase Transportation costs
well I I push back to transport costs to
landfills and I'm going to push back on
that a little bit because of exactly
what you said but hitting pause on this
and following the recommendations of the
study committee which is pursuing
Advanced Recycling and improving
recycling methods and uh and things like
that um you conceivably reduce the
amount that you're hauling to landfills
I mean that one one could think that
that that would uh that would do that
the other topic was incineration
incineration Will eliminate a third of
what's goes into the landfills um and
again these are you know I know there
those are hot but button issues as well
but they're issues that need time to be
vetted and uh and and that's exactly
what this build does it gives time to to
further explore Advanced Recycling and
in and implement it consider
implementing it in New Hampshire I think
one of the things we found out in uh our
committee over the summer is New
Hampshire is the only the only state in
the Northeast that doesn't it's lagging
it's the last state in the Northeast uh
W with efforts on recycling we know that
um um compost 30% of the stuff that we
throw away is compostable that's filling
up uh a space in our in our landfills so
yeah this pumps the brakes says you know
let's let's look at what we can do aside
from this let's get our rules right
let's uh we don't have a we don't have a
gun to our head we don't have we don't
have a capacity issue right now uh and
this just buys us time to to make the
Right Moves make do the right things
thank you thank you madam chair
representative rosart um so did your
study committee come up with 2031 as a
as a date or how did that date come up
yeah so the um that's a good question
and so the study committee stopped at a
moratorium or a pause should be
considered uh could be considered we
didn't get into the details too much the
the 2031 came up based on the uh banial
Solid Waste report um which estimated uh
capacity needing further capacity in
2034 I didn't print that out because
it's 100 and plus pages but that's the
banial solid waste report um that's on
the dees website it's on page seven that
says the uh um capacity may fall short
projected in 2034 so considering 2031
three years buys us some time um to get
a permit to get get to get a facility in
place and does it take three years to
get a facility put in place that I don't
know
okay all right thank you any other
Penza I just want wanted to ask if you
feel comfortable in um uh basically an
application that's sitting out there
during the same time that rules are in a
sense being processed does that make you
feel comfortable because in a sense you
know rules are being developed at the
same time there's an application in
there
and is that part of the reason why in
putting a moratorium in here because
there is not a definite need at this
point and there isn't for another 10
been down here a year and uh I can tell
you the folks up north as everywhere
we're looking for an answer on some
stuff we have needs we have crazy things
like 250 feet you can put a landfill 250
fet from a body of water and you
know those things are common sense we
would think but we can't get a consensus
on on what what what the right way to go
is I mean this house has bipartisan uh
passed bipartisan bills to to to make
Common Sense changes and it gets to the
other side of the wall and it dies um
we've had cases where you know both h
both bodies have passed something gets
to the corner at office and dies
meanwhile you've got forever chemicals
rolling into our
Rivers um right Upstream from my town
who's invested hundreds of thousands of
dollars to revitalize as a downtown and
uh and and and we're thinking this is
crazy why isn't anybody doing anything
on that so does it am I concerned about
that you know a couple things yeah I'm
concerned that we we haven't done the
right we haven't we've getting Common
Sense stuff through down here hasn't
happened we've got we've got places all
over the state being Newington and and
and marac and and all we just placed
replaced two wells in the state of New
Hampshire for schools because of
contamination and we're still not
getting anything done down here that
concerns me um it would concern me as a
applicant to have an application in
there knowing the rules might change I
mean I I I can't imagine putting up an
investment like that uh knowing that the
uh the dees might change the rules
Midstream so yeah there's a lot of
concerns I have a lot of concerns there
and uh I think that this is a it's a
common sense thing um I mean it's a
pause it's a you know we do this in my
Ways and Means Committee we do this with
historical race horsing we' we've put a
pause on things because HR gambling it's
it's a contentious issue but regardless
of what HR does it doesn't poison
Wells and if we can put a moratorium on
a electronic machine that you know
people gamble on why can't we put a
moratorium on something that could
poison our drinking water representative
NAB thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question um I wonder did your
committee hear from private uh landfill
companies and did they have any push
back on this legislation or Yeah we
actually did we heard uh and and the the
the reports online and again I gave you
the first few pages of that uh we heard
from representatives from carbury uh
landfill and I think maybe Wast man
management um some of the folks may be
here in the room um and we did we did
hear from them and you
know they were very re I mean I I didn't
they want to do the right thing too I
I'm not here to demonize anybody I mean
uh we all understand every single one of
us throws stuff away I mean like you
said earlier I mean it's it's the stuff
that we deal with um you got they're
doing the best they can they're they're
they're they're they're trying to do it
to the high highest standards that's
around um and uh and I think their their
feedback was receptive and it was we we
they were respectful um I've had nothing
my interactions with them in this
capacity have been nothing but um
top-notch and uh I think they're an
industry that really want to do the
right thing too and we just have to work
together to find out the pathway that
best suits both sides representative
rord thank you for that thank you
appreciate that any other questions
questions seeing none I'd like to call
speak thank you yeah my name is Jared
Sullivan representative for grafting 2
which is Bethlehem and Frank conia the
one of the bills or sorry one of the
landfills that is so contentious is in
my town of Bethlehem
um I'm going to be as quick as I can
because I have to get back up to my
committee where two of my bills are in
the middle of a working session and we
haven't just got to them yet so um
anyways I'm just here to talk about the
fiscal node it was somebody asked me
well David asked me to look at it he
thought it didn't quite make sense and
so I thought I would look into it and
there are a few things in here that I I
I feel like we should flag
so um for starters they're talking about
there being no impact on fiscal years 24
and 25 they're saying that they do not
anticipate an impact on the state or
local expenditures
so I guess everything starts in 2026
because that's when it's anticipated
that the Bethlehem uh landfill will
close down um it doesn't matter whether
this bill passes or not the Bethlehem
landfill will close down even if
something changed and we were able to
extend the Bethlehem or do the expansion
at the Bethlehem landfill uh I've spoken
with Cella and they have I've been there
several times on on the site and got a
tour of the landfill because this is a
super hot bu an issue in my town as you
can imagine they've told me that even if
the Dalton thing does get approved or
somehow Bethlehem revers course and we
did expand the Bethlehem there would be
a gap in between there starting in 2026
because it takes that much time to build
out so this bill really has no impact of
starting in 2026 that's going to happen
regardless so the fact that that entered
this methodology in the fiscal note is a
little concerning um because those costs
are going to increase regardless if if
that's what they inue believe will
happen so there their logic is you know
in their economic analysis of of the
impact of this bill is that you're going
to see a decrease in the supply of
landfill space or a capacity to deal
with waste right and and that that that
is true you're going to see that and
that generally does when you see
decreases in Supply things costs do go
up but it that's kind of looking at it
in a vacuum and I think that in in this
world there are other things that happen
so when prices of a one thing happens
generally the substitutes react and so
you know if if the cost of Coca-Cola
went up dramatically would all switch
and start consuming Pepsi instead right
and Pepsi could start producing more
because they would have a market
opportunity well it's reasonable to
assume that certainly in the medium term
Maybe not immediately but the medium-
term if we decide not to increase our
landfill capacity in the state that
other things would step into fill that
void because it would be a market
opportunity again this bill doesn't I I
think this is a really key point this
bill does not impact whether or not the
Bethlehem landfill is going to close
it's going to close regardless of
whether we extend extend the life in
Bethlehem in the future or have Dalton
the this capacity problem happens with
or without this bill and this bill this
fiscal note suggests that the problems
from a financial standpoint start to
occur on 2026 it's just not true it
doesn't make sense and I hope that you
guys can you know use that clear flawed
methodology to discredit this part of
the fiscal analysis um with that I'll
open up questions and if not I'll run
back to my committee any questions
representative
kulan thank you Mr Speaker and thank you
for taking my question representative um
yeah with I heard what you said about
the um increases and um you made some
good points on the economic thing but
living in Grafton County like a lot of
our constituents myself included we have
private waste so one thing that worries
me about bills like this is that we
can't really see too far into the future
right because you know the world in 2019
is a lot different you know than it is
today and we didn't see these un you
know unforeseen things or we do live in
an uncertain world so is there any kind
of concern that you have about um you
know Waste Management prices rising
between now and 2031 and you know
because that does impact our
constituents and our own uh Waste
Services costs my costs have gone up in
this past year alone so I'm just
wondering if there's any concerns uh
regarding prices so if your prices have
gone up in the past year it's not
because of this bill obviously so I
think the market forces that drive cost
increases are anything from National
inflation problems that we've we've all
seen increases in gas pric or oil prices
that drive you know these vehicles that
pick up our waste um labor shortages so
you have to pay people who work and
drive these trucks and these waste
removal uh service companies have to pay
their staff more like all of those
things are going to drive the cost
they're going to pass that on to you if
you're going to look at this bill
specifically the relevant question is
does this bill prevent capacity from
coming on and the reality is it might
but it's not clear that that's entirely
true right and so we know that the
Bethlehem thing is not scheduled to be
expanded because the town won't won't
allow it they've already like voted it
down at the Town level the Dalton Thing
Remains kind of in the air last I
checked um that might come it might not
but it's certainly not going to come in
2026 and if it does if it does pass uh I
don't I can't speak to how long it would
take to develop it but uh if 20 it's
definitely not going to be by 2026 27 so
it' be some point between then and 2031
which is what the moratorium is
suggesting whether or not that happens I
don't know so I guess you could make an
argument that if the assumption that the
Dalton thing will be developed then
potentially there could be an increase
potentially compared to the status quo
um I don't know that you could I don't
know if that's a super reasonable
assumption you have to you have to make
some real assumptions to get to that
outcome that prices will increase
because of this bill prices might very
well increased because of the
inflationary environment or whole host
of other reasons but because of this
bill that feel feels like a stretch to
information represent Murray thank you
madam chair um and thank you for taking
my question um with regard to the waste
disposal hierarchy we know that
landfilling is our least preferred
method of dealing with the things that
we consume buy purchase all of the other
things and um I also noted in um the
report that was issued uh that was
associated with the prime sponsors uh
testimony that we're only 20 26%
recycling rate for the State of New
Hampshire and I think that we have
our uh triangle upside down right now um
so our desire would be to be recycling
more and landfilling less would you not
agree I mean sure ideally I mean I'm I'm
not an expert of the best way to deal
with our waste problems but there's
plenty of material to be recycled than
it should be
recycled um my understanding is
recycling rates across the entire
country are quite low uh but I don't
want to pretend like I'm an expert on
this I'm not an expert on why we recycle
what we recycle and why we don't recycle
what we don't recycle compared to other
nations or other parts of the country
even
um on that point I would say that there
are a lot of things that could be
recycled that perhaps aren't
recycled and I know in my town of
Bethlehem we're like one of the only
towns in the North country that actually
has curbside pickup and in it we have
all the recycling thrown into one bin
and from my understanding much of it
just gets landfilled anyways and doesn't
get separated I think basically the
metal gets separated out uh again don't
don't hold me to that I'm not an expert
on it this is just what I've been told
um but I think recycling yeah recycling
is important I think if we can create a
market for that stuff or if there is a
market for that stuff I think from an
economic standpoint I'm an economist
that's why I was asked to come speak
here from an economic standpoint you got
to ask why are we not recycling things
and I don't know the answer to that but
if there's a market for the stuff why is
it not being recycled does it take a
government nudge to force Us in that
direction or is there some sort of
market failure that is causing us to is
it is it a lack of infrastructure for
recycling stuff that makes recycling
more expensive than landfilling
currently and I think that's actually a
pretty interesting question that it
would be good for somebody to kind of
look at or explain I don't know the
answer to it but um certainly is
preferable to recycle holding alls
constant thank you and one followup if I
so to that end I guess if if we increase
all of our other things like I believe
maybe was mentioned in the other
testimonies and we do other waste
diversion composting recycling um is it
your assumption that the the impact and
burden
of uh capacity might slow down with
these other efforts sure yeah I mean
that that's a very logical assumption
and also uh I mean one of the big
concerns with landfills and I know I'm
not educating anybody on this topic but
just to say it because it needs to be
said one of the big concerns about
landfills in this specific location of
Bethlehem or the Dalton facility is
that the potential for leaking into
water that's very close with the poest
soil is is pretty high and that's the
concern we're not saying we need no
landfills obviously we need landfills
this gives us time to kind of figure
that out and in that process maybe there
are other Solutions which right now will
be considered because there's sort of
the default the status quo and there's
always status quo bias in every decision
making and we know where the landfill is
and in my town it's right there so why
would we have robust recycling
facilities in my town or maybe the
surrounding towns when you have a
landfill right there but yeah if you can
get more recycled then that that does
seem um like it might reduce capacity
needs in the future for actual landfills
representative ger thank you madam chair
thank you for taking my question uh and
with regard to capacity uh the provision
in the bill that would allow for the
expansion of existing facilities
providing more capacity would also
counter inflationary pressures right in
terms of of the market not inflationary
per se but we have the Capac we have the
ability through this bill to add
capacity which should help prevent the
increase in costs correct yeah I mean
the the bur the Berlin one um I mean
that's presumably where the stuff and my
town will go when this when this
landfill that we currently have
closes there's no reason why they can't
expand I that this doesn't prohibit that
and that that is a bu a landfill that
from my understanding is a good landfill
in terms of it's not sitting on poor
soil it's sitting on a clay based soil
so if if we're going to have uh
expansions of other ones the capacity
problems may or may not materialize like
I think in the very very short term
there's going to be capacity problems
regardless of this bill because of what
I laid out when I first started my
testimony but I I think that you know if
that does drive up prices guess what's
going to happen the Market's going to
work and and the landfill in in Berlin
for example will likely
Penza are you familiar with um with
Dalton switching um over to a new
Bethlehem uh you mean they don't use the
Bethlehem landfill correct somebody has
told me that yeah I I I don't know where
it goes right now so they actually
switched to carbury is there a question
about this bill it it is okay um they
switched to carbur which was less money
which in talking about the money piece
here but in doing so realizing that
there is still plenty of capacity with
the New Hampshire piece so because you
have to be able to take New Hampshire
trash first in a sense so if a landfill
is taking 50% or more then that also uh
negates this with um you know we've got
Recycling and food waste and all that
can you see that to be keeping us to a
point in in um
2031 I mean yeah I think so I I don't
think that this is going to drive up
costs and I think the costs are going to
go up based on what's already in the
pipeline because it takes a while to
build these facilities so this bill is
not what's going to drive any sort of
cost increas is is the argument against
this fiscal note which I don't think was
done very well um I think an an just not
I don't generally live in a world of
anecdotes but I'll give you an anecdote
to your point which is I was doing work
on my my house this summer and getting a
dumpster from cassella which would go to
the landfill in my town was considerably
more expensive than getting one from a
Berlin provider where it went to
Carberry and so I it might just make
sense to expand that area because
they're already jacking up prices in
cassella it's already sort of over
subscribed to it seems like just based
on the market forces that we're
seeing any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
Morrison
good afternoon good
afternoon uh for the record my name is
Wayne Morrison and U I am the President
of North Country Alliance for balance
change which is a big title for a small
group of volunteers who don't get paid
for any of the work that they do but
I've spent the last four or five years
uh working very very hard with a
coalition of people to try and make
changes and and reform some of the
regulations particularly around landfill
sighting um but also in protecting clean
water uh all across the state so I know
you've had a long day and I'm sure it's
a long week the testimony I gave you I'm
going to take a leap of faith and I'm
going to kind of set that aside I'm not
going to try and read it I hope you will
it's uh it's it's was put together with
a lot of uh care and tried to express
myself in terms of why I support this
bill but I think for the for the time
that I have with you I'd really like to
focus my attention on U why do we need
to
pause and why
um there are multiple Solid Waste
warning lights flashing in the state of
New
Hampshire some of them are flashing
yellow and some of them are flashing red
and it's important that this group the
legislature pay attention to those and
finally to act on
them business as usual in the
landfilling business is not going to be
particularly good for New
Hampshire we have a booming outdoor
recreation
economy and we need to protect the
health and the environment and the and
we need to protect uh the best interest
of our Citi cens and our
businesses the pause gives the
legislature a chance first to evaluate a
bunch of moving parts that we don't
particularly have answers to today but
we need to get answers and then we need
to
act I want to start I have five points
that I would like to raise with the
group the first one being you've heard a
lot about
capacity and I am here to tell you after
diving into this and spending
hundreds of hours trying to understand
how Dees and how our system works in
calculating
capacity we absolutely do not have a
capacity situation today and the
2034 date that is quoted in the banial
report I hope all of you know that that
date is a function of a model that Dees
uses I'm not against models but they're
only as good as the Fe back and the data
that you feed into
them and if you explore that model and
if Mike whim was here director whims was
here he would tell you that 2034 is not
a date that's really meaningful because
it that that capacity shortfall starts
because we assume the largest landfill
in the state operated by waste
management is going to shut
down that's not going to happen they are
going to expand and they're going to
continue to run the largest landfill in
the
state 2034 is likely to be 2044 or 2054
depending on the capacity that they add
at that
time so in in considering the actions we
need to take it is clear that the
legislature and the state has plenty of
time to try and Wade through some
difficult problems and to the extent
that we can we won't get it perfect but
we certainly will get it better than we
have in the past and now is the time to
do that it could we couldn't have a
better time so the pause is
important and the timing this is the
perfect time to
stop secondly my second
point the state went essentially 19
plan that action or lack of action was
extremely
detrimental to our Solid Waste position
relative to Massachusetts relative to
Vermont relative to Maine while we were
essentially ignoring the solid waste
problem other states were taking all
kinds of
actions that has made us very attractive
to the private operators in the solid
waste business it is not a surprise it
is it is not a difficult problem to see
why trash is coming to New Hampshire our
laws are behind the times and they are
more LAX than our neighboring
states after 19 years Karen eel and the
solid waste working group put a year
working
diligently with Dees to develop an
updated
plan and guess what that plan says the
overarching goal of that plan is to
reduce the amount of solid
waste going in needing disposal by
25% what does that mean well that's
calculated based on how much Municipal
solid waste and how much construction
and demolition material that we
produce 25% as it turns out when you do
the math is 370,000 tons a year by the
year
and just to put that in perspective if
we were to hit that goal those numbers
are bigger than the two or the three of
the largest landfills that currently
operate in the state so if we were
successful we would eliminate the need
for one
landfill so I asked this group why on
Earth as we sit here in 2024 would we
even be considering adding additional
capacity before we even have a chance to
see how are we going to do against that
goal isn't that where the state of New
Hampshire should be putting its energy
isn't that where the investment should
be
going the solid waste working group and
the and the state's Solid Waste
Management plan says we should be in the
diversion business not the landfilling
business we should be worried about
composting and recycling reuse we should
not be looking to knock down trees and
kill wetlands and make more space for
more
landfills
our neighboring states are closing
landfills and they are shipping their
trash to New
Hampshire we should all be very upset
about that our neighbors to the South
are fixing their problem by
making making it our problem and by the
way it's not only the trash they sent
us but that trash is turning into
lee8 and you should think of lee8 as PE
landfills
are essentially P
factories they produce millions and
millions of gallons of
lee8 every
year and that has to
be collected stored pumped transported
and treated somewhere in the
state and that puts New Hampshire
citizens and New Hampshire businesses at
risk every single day and although the
industry wants to tell you about doubled
line systems and monitoring
Wells let me tell you they all
leak and we don't the last thing that we
need is another landfill when we don't
need the capacity and we're going to
problem the third thing is the change in
the updating of the dees
rules
nobody that I talk to anywhere in the
state can tell me when was the last time
we had a new landfill most of them are
organically grown from dumps that that
somebody Acquired and grew we haven't
had a Greenfield landfill in in anyone's
memory we should at least make sure
before we ever have another new landfill
we are using the latest rules the
tightest possible regulations to protect
our resources and our
people
fourth new tougher regulatory standards
are under review for forever chemicals
pasas which are abundantly present in
every bit of the luche that gets
produced top toxic chemicals are one of
the reasons landfilling is at the very
bottom of the state's Solid Waste
hierarchy we we make beautiful
PowerPoint slides that say here's the
hierarchy and at the very bottom tip the
last thing the the the the the move of
Last Resort is to create a
landfill and then our behavior is the
exact inverse the first thing we do is
we've got a capacity problem let's
either expand or let's add a new
one what are we doing now is the time to
change
direction the last item I want to talk
to you
about is that the overarching problem
taxing New Hampshire Sol ID waste
management system is the unlimited
importation of outof State waste by
private
operators everything else pales in
comparison to that whether it's 40%
50% if we keep on the track that we're
going it's going to be 60% there's no
stopping it and to my understanding Dees
has no control over that they can't
limit it we are letting private
operators dictate our solid waste
obscene I do not blame Dees it has taken
an executive branch a legislative branch
and the Department of Environmental
Services to get us where we are
today but guess what we can fix all of
that Dees cannot do that alone they
cannot fix the aate waste problem but
you
can there are bills coming your way
there are actions we can take this pause
is so important because if we don't
pause the risk is that we're going to
let another private operator open a new
landfill and guess what we are going to
institutionalize out ofate waste for
decades and decades to
come and while you guys go off and look
at other things and a million other
bills and you've got all kinds of
priorities
people in the North country are going to
have to live with that
decision and it won't be
me it'll be the next generation and the
generation after that that will not get
to
experience the
Beauty and the environment and all those
things that make New Hampshire New
Hampshire and it's why our out of our
outdoor recreation industry is
absolutely booming it's why people want
to come here
now is exactly the time to pause to
focus to seek both Technical and policy
solutions to ensure that if and when we
actually do need another landfill by God
we get it
right we're not ready to do that now
Dees is not in a
position to make the kind of
decisions that reflect a 100-year
commitment that that one of these
landfills ends up
being
I know this sounds like a radical
proposal to
pause but sometimes that's what you need
to get perspective and
focus and the people of New Hampshire
deserve
that again I will
say I'm not anti-b business I spent my
entire life with a working in Fortune
business but the businesses I want to
support are the restaurants and the
shops and the breweries and all those
businesses that are doing well in our
state and one landfill puts all of that
at
risk particularly one that we don't need
and one that will serve the needs of
Massachusetts as much or more than it
will the people of New
Hampshire please please vote ought to
pass and support this
questions any questions from the
Jones
uh to the esteemed members of committee
thanks so much for making the time today
my name is Haley Jones and I the Vermont
and New Hampshire state director with an
organization called slingshot where we
work alongside communities most impacted
by environmental health issues to build
local power and take aim at polluters we
partner with people from communities who
are most impacted by environmental
problems whether we're talking about
leaking landfills or P Fass in your
water and we train folks from all walks
of life in the skills that they need to
make change in their neighborhoods and
Beyond We join leaders together to build
powerful Statewide Regional and National
networks that lay the foundation for
lasting change in the world of
environmental
health I am here today alongside
virtually and physically small business
owners and scientific experts and
Community leaders from from across the
state to testify in support of hb1 1620
to put a moratorium or a pause on new
landfill permits until
2031 we really owe it all uh to Granite
we all owe it to Granite State residents
to think carefully about our waste
management and our landfill s sighting
practices before we rush head first into
a commitment that is going to affect
generations to come and as folks in my
generation say we are not ready to
define the relationship with landfill
sighting yet in New
Hampshire we know that all landfills
leak discharging lee8 into the
surrounding soils where this garbage
juice can travel with really concerning
speed and when you sight landfills on
porous or otherwise unsuitable terrain
this toxic leech a can contaminate
Community water sources before our
Regulatory Agencies as hard as they
might try have a chance to respond and I
know from my line of work that after
seeping through these piles of waste
leate can be carrying lead and arsenic
heavy metals and toxic forever chemicals
like pasas all of which are huge Public
public health concerns we know that
pasas alone are associated with Cancers
with reproductive disorders and serious
developmental problems so it's clear
that whenever we have the opportunity we
need to be preventing their
spread as you've heard in Prior comments
landfill sighting is a high stakes game
and there are corporate polluters out
there who are pushing for permit
approvals that would have us all gamble
with people's lives so I'm asking you
all instead of making hasty decisions
that sacrifice the health of our most
vulnerable towns we need to take this
pause we need to be actively reducing
our Solid Waste production in accordance
with this zero waste TI
and we need to prevent further
devastating pollution we don't want
another Claremont we don't want another
miramac we don't want another Bethlehem
we really really need to take this pause
so I'll just end by saying we know that
now is not the time to play games with
our future and so I'm urging you all to
vote a to pass on 1620 to ensure a
thriving future for all the generations
to come thank you so much for your time
and I'm happy to take
questions
questions seeing none thank you for your
cotch good afternoon good afternoon
Madam chair members of the committee for
the record my name is Kiren cotch the
vice president of public policy for the
business and industry Association we
serve as New Hampshire Statewide Chamber
of Commerce and represent hundreds of
businesses in the state of New
Hampshire I'm here today to express
bia's opposition to House Bill
1620 as established by bia's public
policy priorities we support
science-based environmental policies
that balance Economic Development with
the long-term sustainability of the
state's natural
resources baia has concerns regarding
house bills 1620 because we believe this
proposal fails to strike the delicate
balance between allowing for economic
development and Environmental Protection
firstly We Believe House Bill 1620 is
unnecessary the solid waste rules are
currently already in the process of
being updated by the New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services and
are slated to be done this year further
we're concerned that the year 2031 has
been arbitrarily determined and is an
unreasonably long timeline for a
moratorium un Land Fill permits second
the landfill permitting sighting process
and development process takes years to
complete for my discussions with
technical experts they've estimated this
process takes about 6 to 10 years if all
goes smoothly which we know from recent
experience has been a
challenge um I'd also like to address
line five um in the bill uh there was
discussion about this earlier about Dees
will accept and investigate permits uh
applications during the moratorium time
this line does not alleviate our
concerns because it basically allows for
applications to be held while the goal
post is moved whether it's through rules
or legislation if passed we believe this
bill could ultimately result in a
shortage of instate disposal capacity
resulting in New Hampshire generated
solid Wass having to be shipped out of
state for disposal and these existing
landfills cannot expand
exponentially not only is this
problematic for the solid waste industry
but we believe these changes will have
negative consequences and exponentially
increase the cost of her business in
every industry throughout New Hampshire
additionally shipping waste out of state
has unended consequences such as
dramatically increasing the carbon
footprint associated with instate
generated waste disposal this is one of
the many reasons that are completely
contrary to the both federal and state
carbon reduction goals and should be a
primary reason not to pass this bill in
conclusion bi respectfully requests the
committee to vote inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 162
because if passed the bill would be
damaging to New Hampshire's business
climate future Economic Development and
could also result in in unintended
environmental impacts as affordable
instate disposal capacity becomes more
scarce thank you for your consideration
I'd be happy to try to answer any
questions thank you Miss cotch um I'm
interested to know if
Bia would find um a
lesser pause acceptable I mean if it
wasn't
2031 would you would Bia be amable to
something like you know
2028 something like that in so far as I
mean we've heard testimonies saying that
you know we've got a lot of things going
on we've got rules being developed we've
got uh issues with certain landfills
maybe we just really need to step back
and assess what's going on what we might
need in terms of policy and so forth
um what what's your thought on that
thank you for the question Madam chair I
believe that of course a shorter
moratorium would be a modest Improvement
but with rule changes you know being
updated this year already I'm not sure
if it's
Penza I have two questions um first
question um has the Bia um read the the
report the final report for the study of
unlimited service area permits for land
Sills out of waste thank you for the
question I've reviewed it
briefly so then my second um question
would be how can you say that the bill
could cause a capacity issue when the
state says
otherwise I think we're under the belief
that you know if it takes 6 to 10 years
to permit and and we're concerned about
capacity starting in 2034 then you know
there okay thank you um representative
Howard thank you madam chair um I have
two questions too first of all um you
know the the Bia is probably concerned
with job generation and do you do you
anticipate that that more that building
the these anticipated um uh landfill
would create jobs or what what is the
business opportunity in building more
landfills thank you for the question
well I represent the greater business
community so I can't specifically
discuss um you know what the solid waste
industry is looking for here but of
course it would generate more
jobs and my second question is uh
regarding science you say you use
science-based um information to make
your decisions
um uh Could you um sort of explain where
you know what scientific body you're
using to to determine these things thank
you for the question um I believe I said
policy um in communicating with uh
technical experts within our membership
environmental
experts representative German thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question uh I'm a college professor true
to form I'm going to be pedantic about
uh about the letter here uh you indicate
uh we believe these these changes will
have negative consequences and
exponentially increased costs for
businesses in every industry uh um so
leaving aside for a moment the actual
technical definition of
exponential I'm assuming this is a more
um a less precise term meaning just
rapid as opposed to literally
exponential but can you tell us this
goes a little bit to repres resentative
Howard's question how you've determined
that have you run models what specific
data do you have that you could provide
the committee that would demonstrate
that there would be a rapid large
increase in costs to Industry throughout
the state thank you for the question um
this information is anecdotal from our
members we know that if they have to pay
to send their waste out of state for
disposal that's going to cost more the
further they have to send it if they're
shipping their waste to Ohio for
disposal that's going to cost more than
keeping it in state thank
you representative Bixby yeah just to
follow up on the the question of jobs um
I'm wondering if in the uh process of
looking at the the the employment
prospects for the North Country uh as
the result of a you know either having
another landfill up there or not uh
would the landfills provided by the by
would the jobs provided by the landfill
uh offset the potential loss of jobs in
the tourism
industry thank you for the question I I
think it's a a good question to look
into but I I don't have the answer
representative Murray um thank you um
and thank you for taking my question so
my other question to you around jobs
would be is is there not the potential
for other if if this bill were to go
forward is there a potential for other
jobs in in ancel ancillary Industries uh
to maybe
uh be developed or come alive as a
result of a pause and a refocus on some
other areas that might be around
recycling efforts or some other types of
um related things that would more
comport to our waste disposal hierarchy
thank you for the question and I would
say certainly um our sub our opposition
here is not just about jobs though it's
about Economic Development and and the
ability for businesses to thrive in New
Hampshire so it's not limited to just
that
um interested to know excuse
me how did you get to the number that it
takes six to 10 years to permit a new
landfill um in discussions with our
technical experts and our membership
environmental experts we're talking
about you know from the beginning of the
application process to the actual
development of a landfill is that
something that um a number that you
have also verified with Department of
Environmental
Services I have not spoken them with
them directly about verifying that
number but I'm sure they could attest to
that in their
testimony okay I don't see any other
pink cards so I don't
know um
okay representative Murray um yes thank
you I I did have one other question or
comment could you speak to I there are
currently situations in where um some of
our waste is already disposed of out of
state for various Natures if it it's a
toxic substance or some other entity
where we don't deal with that in the
state which portion are are you
referring to where there would be an
increase in out of state
disposal thank you for the question I I
think the scenaria I'm referring to in
that situation would be if if we no
longer had enough capacity in New
Hampshire and had to dispose of our
waste then out of
state thank you any other
questions representative Bixby yes do
you know if your experts took into
account in their assessment of timing uh
the fact that Dees does not permit
Beyond a certain date uh simply because
it is their policy to have uh end dates
on permits but the permit does that end
date does not imply that there is not
future capacity it's just the end date
of a particular permit and that permits
can be and are renewed on a regular
years I'm not sure I understand the
question okay so uh
Dees has a cycle of Permitting and the
fact and they uh what the when they say
our current permitted capacity is
through such and such a date say uh
2034 the fact that the permitted
capacity is through 202 2034 doesn't
mean that
suddenly uh the landfills that are
permitted no longer have capacity it's
merely that they will need to renew
their permits and that the capacity the
actual capacity may be substantially
higher in the future than what's
reflected by the permitted capacity is
that do your experts take that into
account when they're looking at the
potential of sending
waste out of state well I think that's a
accurate statement but we're just
judging by what's approved right now
thank
you representative
Penza I have two questions first
question is uh castella waste um
management u a member of the Bia yes
okay second question did the Bia go for
example to um a current area for example
Rochester or Bethlehem and then get all
of those businesses on board with this
and if so I'd love to have a list of
that cuz I went up there in um talk to a
lot of businesses and they are very much
against a new landfill in their area
thank you for the question we have a
policy development process that goes for
our policy advisory subcommittee made up
of executive board members that's how we
come to decisions on
bills so you can't give specific
businesses that support or don't support
this legislation
thank you for the question it's it's
subcommittee okay any other questions
from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much for coming and speaking with us
this afternoon thank you for the
opportunity I have no other pink cards
but I
kerm and I'd like you to fill out a pink
card if you get a chance please yes I
actually sent one up to you and I don't
know where it got to but I'm happy to
fill out another one I gave it to me the
no I get it was for the other bill but I
didn't see one for this
one did it get
lost no problem I can fill out another
one
all you're on okay thank you for the
record my name is Sarah U huskar and I'm
the assistant director of the waste
management division at New Hampshire
Dees and this is leam McKenna
administrator of the solid waste
management Bureau thank you for the
opportunity to testify on House Bill
1620 Dees opposes this bill because it
suspends solid waste per permitting
activities that are important to
maintaining the stability of the solid
waste Market in the state and we
concerned that it could have adverse
Economic Consequences on New Hampshire
communities and New Hampshire businesses
and that concern about The Economic
Consequences is related to the
projections of capacity uh and capacity
need which are
um in some ways difficult to assess uh
it appears that the 2031 date was
selected based on a chart that's in the
solid waste banal
report and the uh um projections in that
report indicate that need will not
exceed capacity until sometime after
2031 I think it's
2035 but it's important to understand
that these projections do not take into
account um important factors such as the
location of the capacity in the state
and also it doesn't take into account
the fact that landfills are able to
accept out of state
waste when you take those factors into
consideration there is a potential for a
capacity need much sooner um year 2627
is what our fiscal note
says while the bill does allow for
permitting of expansions at existing
landfills to continue during this period
of time existing landfills may not be
positioned or inclined to apply for
expansion so so it uh may not
be reliable to solely rely on potential
landfill expansions to solve any
capacity need issues that would arise
time that summarizes our concerns about
the bill and I'm happy to take
questions representative NAB thank you
madam chair thank you for taking my
question I'm curious because it came up
the other day um and because the
previous speaker was just talking about
their process what the process is by
which Dees decides whether to take a
position for or against a bill or to
just offer commentary and remain
neutral uh the process involves
discussion discussing the details of the
leadership representative Duty yes thank
you madam
chairperson um so naswa has capacity out
for 40 years okay in its landfill um so
if nashwa could do that why can't other
landfills um manage their landfills to
have that kind of
capacity it depends on the specifics of
the landfill how much space they have uh
what the geometry of the landfill is um
some landfills have phases of approvals
how much space is left in their phase so
so it's specific to the
landfill representative Howard thank you
madam chair um most of the reasons that
you gave for opposing this bill were
Financial or economic um and isn't your
purview to protect and and take care of
the environment um so I'm just wondering
why you know why bring why cap bringing
in garbage from outside and and keeping
that in in income level going is more
important than protecting the
environment uh there are a couple issues
to unpack there uh the first is that yes
our mission is to protect human health
and the environment and the solid waste
management act actually charges us with
both making sure that New Hampshire has
appropriate outlet for its solid waste
and um meeting the goals for the
different types of ways of dealing with
the solid waste and protecting the
environment but uh the economic concerns
are related to that responsibility that
we have to make sure that the solid
waste that does need to get landfilled
can be landfilled in a way that is a
affordable in response to your question
about
um waste from out of state coming into
State Dees does not have authority over
that so we we don't have a way to
control that representative Bixby yeah
so um the question came up with a
previous speaker about how long it takes
to uh permit uh and and uh deploy a new
landfill uh what is the what is the time
frame for uh uh from the initiation of
the the process to uh it becoming open
yes I did hear that in the previous
testimony and it makes sense to me that
the the experts that Bia consulted would
indicate that it was 6 to 10 years
because from the point of um doing the
planning and citing before an
application is ever
submitted uh it it makes sense that it
would take that long to the point of
getting
permitted thank you and and so you're
2027 I mean we we saw one report that
says
2031 and you were saying that um that
that report doesn't take certain
capacity issues into
consideration and that you were mostly
looking at more around
2027 in our in our fiscal note we
indicated that we could see some
decrease in capacity by that time by 20
so that's decreasing do you know what
percentage of decrease in capacity I
don't have that
information okay representative Murray
thank you while we're talking about
decreases here I I was referring back to
the 2021-22 banial solid waste report
that your department uh issued and I was
looking at the roughly one and a half
million tons of waste that was noted as
being disposed of between mssw and CN D
um in the year 2018 and we are at a 7%
reduction uh as compared to um 2018 in
1.3 maybe 1.4 million tons um were uh
disposed of in the year 2022 so we are
trending in the right direction of
disposing of less uh albe it slowly but
it seems like there are incremental
decreases in year-over-year changes from
2020 all the way to 2022 with some
fluctuation so I didn't know if you
expect those Trends to continue or not
and if you could speak to
that we do hope and expect those Trends
to continue and uh with implementation
of increased recycling increased
composting all of the things that our
Solid Waste plan which is a 10-year plan
uh proposes to have implemented we would
further representative
Penza I have a couple questions if okay
so um the report says 2034 though not 20
31 and I just wanted to correct that so
which report the one that you were just
saying that okay yeah um
so in any case I wanted to understand
about capacity and it's true that with
all of the permit applications 100% New
Hampshire comes first
correct we come first we have to be able
to take care of our waste before anyone
else
correct I don't really understand your
question in the permit application that
someone's putting in for for a landfill
so the current landfills preference 100%
trash preference in the permit
application I'm sorry I'm not
following I'm not trying to be
obtuse are you trying to say that when a
landfill operator
accepts um solid waste that they have
100% preference refence to that coming
from New Hampshire and then what comes
from out of state correct in the
planning of the B do our do our waste
[Music]
operators uh have any kind of preference
to where the waste is coming from when
it comes to their facility I mean will
they they
won't they they take New Hampshire trash
before they would take out of state
trash
no yes Dees does not uh is not able to
set a limit or a percentage of no in
state as opposed to out of state trash
that the landfills will
accept can I'm not hang on no no hang on
then then go ahead representative Penza
yeah I'm not saying it's like a
preference or anything like that it's
it's truly an obligation it's in the
permit it says says that you shall
guarantee capacity for New Hampshire
it's a New Hampshire Reed to take New
Hampshire waste yes okay
yes
okay representative
Howard thank you madam chair um the
current rules uh expire in July is that
right the current um about landfills
they're working on new rules that will
take place in so the current permit um
application that's will that will the
old rules apply or the new rules um if
as that as that progresses through the
system that's a question that we've
posed to doj and I don't have the answer
today
okay represent Penza so in the current
um application that um Dees
has they state in there that application
came in can you give me exactly when
that application came around time
October okay so October they're
basically saying uh that they can take
trash in
2027 so how is that 6 to 10
years I'm not prepared today and it
wouldn't be appropriate for me to speak
about any permit application that we are
currently
reviewing okay any other questions from
the
committee seeing none I want to thank
you for uh your testimony today thank
you and we'll see you tomorrow all right
any other uh persons who would like to
speak on this
please and uh from our online portal we
have
337 people signed in support of this
opposition and on our blue
sheet
favor and with that I'm going to close
1620 and I guess it's a wrap for today
we'll see you all bright and early